hello everyone welcome back to another
video by simply now this is annual and
in today's video we will be talking you
through the moon stack we will be
learning about mongodb expressjs react
js and node.js but before we begin if
you haven't subscribed to our channel
already make sure to hit the subscribe
button and press the bell icon so you
will never miss any update from simpler
mud is a javascript based software stack
for creating dynamic web pages and
online applications mern application can
be developed in one language for both
server side and client-side execution
because all the components of the months
tag supports javascript programming so
let's see what we are going to learn in
this course
first we'll see what is mongodb and how
to install it after that we'll see
advantages and disadvantages of mongodb
moving ahead we'll see what is
express.js after that we'll see the
features of express.js and then how to
install express.js moving ahead we'll
see how to create an express js stress
api and after that we will see what is
react.js moving ahead we will see the
features of react.js and how to connect
server side to the client side and then
we'll see what is node.js its use cases
and its industrial trends hello
everybody and i welcome you all
so
today as you know it very well
we're gonna start working with the
mongodb
and
this particular topic which we have
decided to work on it is very
interesting in this current scenario
because if you see carefully lot many
companies are moving towards nosql
database
and there is a reason behind is why
mongodb is very very popular
so it is not actually replacing your
existing rdbms which is there in the
market but it is giving you complete
different approach
where you can be completely free
from all those restrictions what a
traditional idb message is going to
offer it to you
so in this particular tutorial we will
be learning
what mongodb is all about and their
advantages and some practical
demonstrations so let's get started now
so here in mongodb we would like to
discuss about what is the mobodb so as
we know the mongodb is known to be
called a traditional
document based database
okay which stores the data in a document
okay nosql means
it doesn't says like no to sql instead
it says not only sql that means
it is not only sql but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
hierarchical relationship using the
single records
that means how the records are related
with each other so that's how exactly it
represents
and it is a pure schema free environment
so that you really do not need to have
a schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema less
involvement
due to that it is giving you far more
better flexibility when you talk about
completely unorganized environment
so what is nosql so the here's the idea
about a nosql
so it is completely into the
non-relational database like
traditionally if you see
any non-relational database
you talk about
a typical nosql
it's purely into the document base here
nosql does not use any tables like in
rows and columns a traditional idp base
approach if you see there they are using
a complete table structure like they
talk about columns they talk about rows
and are all about
so here
in nosql it stores a relationship data
in the documents so the different type
of nosql databases are available like
you talk about called document based you
talk about key value base you talk about
white column based
and graph based
different options are available for the
nosql but the one which we are using it
mongodb it is a purely document based
database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mobo db installation works and
the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're gonna start
working on the first option called
mongodb installation
okay
see mongodb installation is very simple
if you open a website and go for
this website name called
mongodb
download
if you talk about mobile db download
you're gonna see
the official website called mongodb
community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
mac os it by default detected my
platform however you can select
depends on which platform you have it
and after that you will be clicking on
this download
okay so
it will get ready for if you are from
windows
i would say in this windows
you can
select
appropriate option like two options are
available you can talk about msi or talk
about zip
my recommendation is you can stick to
the zip power portion because it won't
start any mobile db services behind the
scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want the mobility to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so
here once the mongodb is there so you
will be seeing that two files available
inside the mongodb folder inside the bin
so once you download the zip you will
find two different type of files are
available let me mention those
so inside the bin folder
you will see two files one is called
mongodb
okay the other file which is available
called mobo
mobo d is to basically start the mongod
server
and the mongodb is actually the client
which will connect with the mongodb
clear so if you are in
windows environment
so once you are inside this bin folder
of your
zip file
you will get the mongod so you have to
double click on this it will start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the
another binary file called [ __ ] so it
will get start as a client
okay since i am using the macbook here
the concept is little
different about how mongodb
can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the moon is being used into your code
okay everyone so now
as we are in the
macbook so here to start mongodb we have
a very special way to start with so here
i'll start with my terminal
and here i would like to paste one very
simple command to start my mongodb
database
that is called mongod
and after that you have to say hyphen
iphone db path it is the place where
your database will be starting and one
more important thing i forgot to mention
like
moody would not start automatically
inside your
windows machine unless
inside your c drive you have to create a
new folder name called data and under
this you have to create a new folder
name called db
because automatically when the mongod
starts
it looks inside the c drive data inside
a db folder there your all records will
get stored so do not forget whenever
you're trying to use the mongodb so you
must make have you must have this
particular
fold structure
in place in your local machine otherwise
this is not going to start
every time you start your mongodb
without this
location it automatically terminates so
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data db folder ready with you
however you can also change the location
of this particular folder structure for
which we will discuss it little later on
but as of now
we can see i'm giving my
location that is called iphone 7 db path
slash data db
i hit enter you can see now my mobile db
is starting now
and since it's stuck so i have to start
the new terminal now
so here i open the another tab
and type [ __ ]
and the moment i type mobile now you can
see it is now connected with my mongodb
and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
now
to check
which other databases are available to
you so you can just type show
dbs
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there
inside your existing
newly installed
mongodb but you can go back and create
new database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this
database we have very simple option
available here
name call
use
simplydb
if i say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside
let's see now you can see you say you
simplydb it automatically creates though
it is not there but automatically takes
you in while creating those
okay so that means your current database
name for simplydb
so if you're not sure which database you
are in so you can just type dbs
or db
and it will show you that your current
database is simply db
that's it so your database is set
and we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back
in a previous videos you have seen like
how to create a database and
how to identify whether my database is
there or not so if you remember
previously we have created our database
using use keyword so if i just see my
databases which we have created is last
time so how we can check this out we can
say show
space dbs
okay so you can see we have got
database
list but we do not have any database
which we have created last time is
registered here that's quite surprising
because
when we have created our database it
should be listed here but it is not
let's do one more time i'm saying use
sn db
and
i'm saying switch to sldb
now when i say once again show dbs
so i still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason
the reason is according to the mongodb
rule unless we have minimum one
record or collection is stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now i want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb
compared to the relational database
here the table which is actually
an rdb message is called here it is
called
collection
okay
db
is still called db here okay that means
the database will be still called
database
but
row
what you use this word in a traditional
rdbms here it is known as called
document
if you remember i told you
like it is a document based database so
here every single record what you try to
insert it is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document
that's what exactly the difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well
we have to basically go and create a new
collection
okay so what you can say db dot
create
collection and here i can pass my
collection name i can say
demo
collection
so once it is done
i can see it is collection is created
in typical language i can say the table
is created and now when i try to see
same show dbs
i can see my database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and i can see
the details are listed
when i say show dbs but there's a
another alternative option available
where you can just do that without even
saying db.create collection
well
if i want to create a collection i
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection i
can directly use this statement name
called
db
dot
db
dot sl
student
dot
insert
and here
we would like to add the property like a
name
and here we can say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
db.slstudent.insert
and i hit enter you can see the
uninserted one
and surprisingly when you try to say
press enter
you will see this sl student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line
not only create the collection for you
but also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the json based structure and due to that
it goes with the key and value pairs
so db is a predefined keyword sn student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert a
record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one
property called
show
show collections
when i say show collections i can list
down those number of
collections or else i can set tables in
a typical rdbms language which are there
added in my system
so essence student in which i can see
the record is inserted so if i want to
confirm i can simply say
db dot
sl
student dot find find is a function
through which i can list down those
number of records which are added i say
find and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when i say db
dot the name call demo collection
okay
db.democollection.find
i'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when i
write this command called sl student dot
insert it not only
create a new collection for me but also
insert the record into my
table also called a collection
that's where exactly
it is giving you the advantage when you
want the collections to be created along
with the data this is the way how you
can really do this
clear
but
whenever you talk about
db dot create collection many people
always think about what is the
significance of having this db.create
collection
look db db.createcollection is having
its own significance we never recommend
this technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always
bring
some restrictions
some terminology which missed out
whenever you talk about this line
so having this db.create collection you
can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use tptor
collection in what is insert so you
might be thinking what those cappings
you're talking about let me try to brief
you
when i say db
dot
create collection and here we are
providing the first name called support
student
okay when i say student
so after this student
additional parameters what we can pass
is this when i say
capped
colon
true
what are we saying cap colon true so you
are enabling the capping after that the
next parameter i'm going to pass that is
known is called size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose i am saying
5 2
4 and also we are saying 2 8 0 that is
the size of 5 mb and here we are giving
call max
colon
5
what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever we try
to bring this create collection option
so capping true means you are enabling
the capping so what is that meaning is
it is trying to say
in this particular collection name
called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either 5
or less than 5.
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 mb
that means you're trying to say
either
by adding the total number of five
records the collective size of five
document will reach to five mb
okay or else the maximum number of five
documents can be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5 mb and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to
say db.create collection this option is
not possible when you're trying to use
this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.great collection and this is what we
always recommend
well
now we would like to talk about our next
feature here
inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside the
[ __ ] tv now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
mogu tv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called
relational document
and second is called embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use
embedded documents because that helps
you to scale up your application without
any hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
i would say the parent record as well as
the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so
how exactly that is let's take a look
about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying db
dot
i do not have a student collection but
i'm just telling you db.student
dot
insert
here
we would like to add
some records what i'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number i'm just saying
uh
one two three four
you can give anything
now the next one we will talk about
caller name
this name we can say
student one
followed by
the next one i'm talking about which
course the student has registered so we
can say
course
inside this course we would like to say
the course name let's say
course name we are given the course name
called
mca
okay
followed by another property called
duration
okay i'm giving this duration
is called
three
years
like that
after that
this curly braces is closing
that means
see the idea is like you see the course
is an embedded document because from
course you have a few more properties
like in course name and duration
i am closing this and starting the
another
property and that is called address
okay
sorry let me remove from here
and from address
and address we can say one more curly
braces
and inside this address we can say city
giving the name called what
bangalore
another one we are using that is called
state
let me remove this state
colon
ka
okay and the third property we're using
that is called country
here is saying
i that is called india
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and outer document both are
closed
hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have
any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
i will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when i try to say db
dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
i can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object id
and here you might have observed and
then also your option
then what exactly that id is now let me
brief you this id is nothing but a
unique primary key your mongodb has
offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it
so by default with every single document
mobodb will associate this by default
property called underscore id which you
can't even ignore
however you can overwrite
i haven't provided any
underscore id as a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single
mongodb document if you want to override
it you can override
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value
however if you want to override it you
can override the value of underscore id
but you can't change the key name
let's try
with some
another record
so the same record if i try to add
let's go
i'm using call
student two
and here i'm saying one two three four
five here if i want to override it i can
just say underscore
id
colon now i can give the value call what
one zero one
this you need to remember so i'm
overriding this value with one zero one
now adding it now the records are added
now let me call fine now you see this
time the records when i fetched
so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore id in a second record it is
the one which i have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore id as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons
like in composite key which you used to
do
in tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore id
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be
given to you so this is the first way of
how the insert document has been done
will be telling you the another ways
where the other documents are also added
okay
so in the previous examples we have seen
like how we can add the records
but i also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in [ __ ] tv
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for
my
emp equal to now starting with
a typical
object
like this and after that i mean
adding this
and within this i'm adding
the first property called emp
id
colon one
after this
okay now you can see it is not
understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call
uh
you know
the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now
emp id1 and we just give the second
property called emp name
so
emp id
i just
remove this i just say emp id and i say
amp name
colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here
again i'm adding another one that is
called
emp id
colon2
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
colon three
and
colon
qa
add it
okay and this curly braces is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing
and once it is done you come down
and say db
dot
new amp
dot
insert
okay and here you pass the name
of the object called my
afb
and you can see now it is telling you an
inserted tree that is known called bulk
insert when you're inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay
now you simply use
db
dot the collection name is what your new
erp
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object id
okay so that
is a really nice idea to have
the id to be provided
okay remember this statement
so
you understood finally how we can
add the records in a
going forward we will also talk about
which is related to your
update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos
okay but here that is the first thing
which you realize it how we can perform
those kind of operations in very very
simple and straightforward manner okay
everyone so now we have got three
records with us and in case if i'm
planning to perform update on any of my
records how will i do this now so we
have a predefined functions available
name called update function
let's see how this update function can
really work so we use this statement
name called db
dot
what is my collection name which is
known as call our new emp new emp
okay
dot
update
okay
so
what i will do i will say db dot new emp
dot
update here
okay
now when we talk about call update we
have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
emp id what we call emp name so we say
wherever the emp id is this i want to
change what the name how can i do this
now
very simple
to perform this what i would like to do
now
i want to basically add few more records
to give you some more better idea
you can see now here we have a call
admin
id name
so
i just do one thing
i just change the ids
one two three i just say four
iso 5
is 6.
okay
and i
call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find
now we have total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated qa
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now i want to say db
dot
new emp
dot
update
here
i would like to perform the property
like in what
[Music]
name
by the emp name
amp name
colon
i say admin
okay
so i just close that
and i use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value here we are giving
emp name
okay what i want to do
i say wherever the name is admin change
to what
admin new
that name i want to change it
close this
close this
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
1
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here i will see
uh the value called admin new is updated
but i have one more admin called admin
it is not changed and that is something
which you need to notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update
so what mobile dv does it starts from
the top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop it doesn't carry
forward its search process for the next
level of results
and that is something
which is
i really want to do that
so in case if you are planning to change
those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a column name admin
second property we will call manager
let's try to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new
underscore
manager and i want to update multiple
values so what i will do here
i will put
comma and say
multi
colon
shoot
okay saying multi colon true that you
want to say hey i want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions hit enter
this time you can say it is saying
and match to and modify to that means
two records found and two records are
modified let's check there we go we have
got new manager is updated in both the
location
that's something which is really
awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have one more beautiful feature
available inside the mongodb and that is
called how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about upset upset is a
combination of update and insert
let me try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about call update part
you see now
here
we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see what multi true we have
used
now here this
multi true
is we're trying to update but let's talk
about something called manager 2
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records found
but there's one concept available name
called absurd absurd means if i try to
perform upset it means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
i want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi-troop
okay
so
as i can see we're using something
called name
and we're performing this update part
so in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi true
we are saying
abstract rule
when i say absurd rule so what happened
now
they say
n matched 0 and up inserted 2 and
modified with id this that means
when i try to call this find function
you will be seeing now we have a got
the another record has been added are we
clear now
as a new record
so absurd does what absurd says like if
the records are found
i will update it if it is not i will
insert it
that means if i try to
call the same thing manager to
find it is added as a new manager now if
i just try to say
uh
not manager to i will call qa
qa and here we are saying emp equal to
new
underscore qa
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and up sorted zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey i did not find any
uh
inserted part but yes i matched one
record i found one record and the one
record is updated now that is very very
beneficial feature when you really want
to perform absurd so that is the
advantage of upsell that is what's
called update plus insert
very
important feature that depends on the
requirement if you want to add you can
certainly add this so the way we have
tried to add this
up certain part we can also try to
perform the delete part also
okay so mongodb also helps you to
perform the delete part and how you'll
be trying to add it now let's try to
understand here in my code if i want to
perform any delete path i have this
statement name called db
dot
the option we are using it that is known
for collection name emp
uh new emp sorry
dot we have option number remove
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here
let's try to add the id here
or the name which you would like to
import so i want to say like
emp name admin new so we just say
name
okay
and then
name scoreboard
admin new
okay emp name admin new when i say
remove
you can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only
one admin new is available
okay
now in a similar way if i try to remove
the property call
new underscore manager
new
underscore
management hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time that's the benefit of remove
so now you can see we have already
implemented some records
as i seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
now when i try to say db
dot
new emp dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now
when it comes to c in third part we have
seen update part we have seen delete
part we have seen now it's time to
basically fetch the records
so find function we've already seen but
in find function we also have some
conditions so so-called queries so in
case if you want to limit the number of
records into your application you can
also do that
let's see db
dot
uh
new emp
dot
find
clear now so in fine you can also
pick up the specific records too
like when i'm saying dot find and here
we can just say
name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with a name
called admin
because it is a emp name not a name so
let me change back to
now i can say it finds
one record so like that you can also
apply a condition
okay enter your code
now
in a similar line if you really don't
want to offer any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
records to be
shown so you have this function
available name call
limit
to to means only two records now you can
see
though i have three records but it is
only showing me two records because i
have limit
those number of records into my code
also
we can perform sorting in case if you
want to perform the sorting in ascending
and descending order that also you can
also do
so here rather than saying limit
we just put this option name called sort
and in this sort on which property you
want to sort it that also you can
mention so we can just say emp name
okay and using ascending order or
descending order so we can just say
minus one let's go descending order
hit now you can see it is showing a
descending order
now if i just say
minus one if you just say one
what is showing you in an ascending
order so you can pick up the specific
property behalf on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order so
that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search
the records based on the embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added
okay that is
uh let me try to say
show
collections
i will call
sl student
and student
okay
db dot
dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records
now if you want to search the records
based on their embedded properties like
i am talking about address this is one
property name called city
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this
very simple so you say db dot
student
dot
find
okay so inside this file
you can provide the specific properties
like
my outermost property name is called
what address so we are using this option
called
address
dot
dot
city so we say
city
are we clear colon
i'm giving the city name called what
bangalore
okay
let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly braces here hit enter and
you can see now i find two records
because both the records belong to what
bangalore so i'm getting this
city bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
apart of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which
you can
have the conditions based on less than
greater than
or whatever values you would like to
make it
is available and possible
okay so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
i'll be clear
where the range which you would like to
consider so those are also possible like
you can see we have this property name
called what emp id 3 and 6.
i just want to pick up only those
records whose id is greater than
what two so what i can say
db
dot
new
emp
okay
dot
find
and inside this file we can say
the property
okay so what's property we're using emp
id we're saying emp
id here
colon here we'll be using
dollar
jt
gc stands for what greater than colon
we're giving the value called what one
fine
close this
run you can see you have received
three records three four and six
in case if i just look forward for
higher than five
you will see only one record so greater
than
that's called gt
okay
same option if i just say lt
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide
the condition so-called limit as i can
say find emp id the way we provide it so
here i will not use
less than
okay
instead i'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in emp id whatever we have taken
so let me try to take the property call
file and here you're providing emp
id
and then
and we're using other curly braces and
we're using dollar in
is very important property dollar in
colon here you provide the details i'm
saying
inside so the properties 3 4 6 we are
saying
3
comma
6
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this
okay everyone so in our previous example
we have already seen lot many activities
this time we are trying to offer you
something very interesting feature and
that is known as called working with
indexing
see mongodb is one of the most popular
tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how
one particular
uh
document which is huge document in case
if you would like to perform any sort of
indexing inside this how you will be
applying this
so to apply indexing into my code
let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing
and with indexing how you'll be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
okay
so what i will do is in step number one
previous records if i see i have got
four six three four one depends on
what early records we had it
so we had to call
new emp
so db dot new emp
dot find
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three requires with me
now
let me try to apply indexing
without indexing if i want to find a
result what outcome i'm gonna receive so
to know about
how much time it gonna be taking if if i
have a got large number of records with
me i'll be using this statement name
called tb
dot the name is called new emp
dot
explain
and here i will be using one predefined
functionality called
execution stats
execution starts
okay
now here after the execution starts will
be using dot
fine
we'll be using the first property here
okay
and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called emp name
colon
i'm giving the name call
qa
okay let's close
okay
now when i press hit enter execution
stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was
hit enter and now you can see
a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to remember by
default
here when i try to run
it says and return one
advance one need time
total everything it is showing me
but one important thing which you will
see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now
and returned one that means one result
is returned
and the total number of documents
examines three in order to find this
record
just imagine a use case here
when i say total number of documents
examine 3 in case if i ever got millions
of records with me
that means to search the record it will
examine all the millions number of
records to search the result which
certainly gonna be taking huge amount of
time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine
when you have no indexing is available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default
index is applied
on your underscore id db
dot
new emp
um
yeah db.ump dot
when i say
db.newemp.getindex is a predefined
function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore id
that's the
fact because by default
index is applied on underscore id not on
the other properties
so i need to identify
which are the properties are required to
be get indexes
mongodb advantages it is supporting
multi-column indexes
and that's what exactly we would like to
see
so let's see in our next demo
now we will try to apply indexing on our
own property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say db
dot
certainly we will be talking about
called collection name called
new
emp
dot
create
index
here you have to pass
two things number one
on which property you would like to
apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so i'm trying to apply on
emp
name
and i want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon one
hit enter you can see now
it is telling me
like uh
number of indexes before one and number
of indexes after two that means earlier
index was available only on one
particular property now it is applied on
two properties
if you want you can check
now you can see there is another
properties added called emp underscore
now if i try to execute a similar query
which i executed earlier
qa
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here
if i see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one see now earlier the number
of document examined were three but
since this index is applied notice
telling me the total number of document
examined is one so performance is
certainly
improved so to search a document it
won't be searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what
only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact i would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes
into your code
okay
so hope we all are clear and understood
about this concept so let's go ahead and
get this implemented into our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied
indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so it is also a possibilities where we
want to also apply the index on other
number of properties too as you can see
in our existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new emp which
contains
two different properties one is called
emp id and second called emp name
just now we have applied index on our
emp name but in case if i want to apply
index on emp id i'll be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes i'm having
this index applied on two different
properties now we would like to say db
dot
create
index
and here in this db dot create index we
can just
i will say db dot collection name so our
collection name is called new emp new
amp
dot create index
first parameter is certainly the name
of which property we are applying so
here we are saying emp id
and in this amp id we will just offer it
has to be ascending or descending let me
decide descending order
so we are saying
minus one
okay
now let's
press enter and check the status
okay now you can see earlier indexes
which we have created that was 2 and now
it turns to 3 so it is very clear that
index is improving now let's check this
out uh
dv dot
new mp dot get indexes now we have a
total number of three indexes are
available
so you can apply index or
n number of columns if you want
okay at the same time
the way we have created the index in
case if i want to drop an index
so we can also drop so what we can do db
dot new emp
dot
drop index
drop
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which
index so you should have that particular
index name
okay so here
we are providing my index name so it
should not be uh i would say the
traditional name called emp id no it has
to emp id
underscore minus one or
emp name underscore one so this should
be the name i'm saying emp
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the emp name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say emp
name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was
three okay one
okay
now you can see we have a call emp id
and underscore id
so
now we have
only two indexes left
there's no emp name anymore this is how
exactly you can drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in the previous examples of mobodb you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen how to utilize
indexing into our code now in our next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation works see in mobile db
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply some very simple code
snippets into your ongoing
uh i would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate db and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of records are
already added
now if i just want to apply aggregation
now i would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is
see ideally when you talk about call
aggregation
okay so aggregation is nothing but a
call aggregate like rdbms if you see
vehicle aggregation there so the unix
command like you talk about shell
pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of functionalities are
available which we will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things
now here let me try to bring some of the
important
well known
i would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use a
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select
a specific
specific fields
dollar project is designed to select
what is specific fields from the
collection we used to talk about call
what
dollar match
the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it does the
actual aggregation
fine we talk about call dollar
sort
okay it basically sort the document
okay like that there's so many
operations are available that you will
see one by one in our aggregation
behavior now my first example the one
which i want to execute i have a call
student record with me which contains a
student name
okay the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student is
appeared
now here my first requirement is we want
to filter
data based on a section a because
students belong to the different
sections
as you can see now it is they belong to
the different section section a b c d
so i just want to
filter the data based on a section a
okay so for filter out i would like to
use dollar match
let's see how it works so i just would
like to filter out with those students
who belong to the section a
so how we would like to use it now i
will say
db
dot
student dot
aggregate
and inside this we would like to use
this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this
i would like to use another curly braces
and i say
section
a
okay and i close this
close this
close the square bracket close this
okay so db dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is known as aggregate
functionality section a hit enter and
you can see now it lists down all those
students who belong to the section a
okay very simple and straightforward
example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records where the section is a
and we are using and operator
marks is greater than 80. there are so
many students who have a different marks
like 70 19 and whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now
remember
not only the section a
but also marks were greater than 80.
so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we are starting
this curly braces
okay
so
after this match we would like to bring
and
we say dollar
and
and again colon
again we are starting this square
bracket now
okay we talk about what
section a
number one
and after the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say
marks colon and once again
they would like to start
curly braces and here we use
dollar
jt that is called what
a greater than colon
80.
okay
all are closed
so you see like here we ever got this
square bracket and non brackets
so
what else is left
so we recall 80 we are using
another curly braces needs to be closed
here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
again curly braces
again
square bracket
again round brackets
okay
let's see where it has gone wrong so we
are using this
db.student.aggregate we use this
yeah square bracket
then curly braces then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces and we
have a call and operator
after this and we have a call
let's go now square bracket then curly
braces section a
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks
colon
dollar gt
okay and we are using what
colon
80
after that we are closing this
and using two more curly braces square
bracket in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that so
db.student.aggregate and like this it
will be able to get it now okay so in a
previous example that was the only
missing point was after this
uh
this dollar match we didn't apply this
curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and i
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this i would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now i
just would like to bring selective
fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything i'm getting it
so i really don't want to bring all the
properties from this document i would
like to selectively take specific
property
so
let's talk about how we can use this so
we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select
the specific record
so
i just use this statement name called db
dot
student
okay dot
aggregate we're using it now after that
now square bracket
and curly braces
now we are trying to say
dollar
project
what we would like to use dollar
project and colon we are trying to use
student name
okay colon
okay remember one thing one means i want
those zero means i don't want so
whichever property will be enabling it
by giving the one as a digit that means
it is
it is expected to be displayed so i'm
saying one
comma i'm saying section
column
one
okay and i'm also
looking forward for marks
colon one that's it so now
you can see now i am once again picking
up only those
like student section and marks now if i
go back and remove some properties like
i only want
student and section you can see i have
only student and sections
are used
here if i just use this statement name
call
underscore
id colon 0
now you can see only
the names
and sections are visible id is not
because i really don't want id by
default id is shown but if i says is
zero that means the id will not be
visible here so like that you can select
the columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way another
thing i would like to use
what if we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from student once
again we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my implementation
if you see the previous one what we have
used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this dollar match
this is the curly braces i'm giving
section
colon
a
okay section colon a and after this i'll
close this
okay
and close this again
again i'm opening it up
by using this option called
project
dollar
project we're picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again
and say
student name
student name
colon we're using one
comma
section colon one
and
one
marks colon one and now
closing this
now you can see i got those so the
requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from student
collection where the section is a
so you are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection
gives you lot many opportunities
which you can utilize it for your own
and also it comes with lot many
predefined functions like in some avgn
and all
so let's talk about those
functionalities too
so this is the first thing which we have
seen aggregations are taking place
now in case if you would like to perform
the group like if i want to find out a
total marks
group by
okay
section like each and every section i
would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how do i basically
do that
so let's try to get this example also
so here
let me try to
go back
and we will not be using match here
because i would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly braces
we want to use
dollar
group
okay that is called group by in rdb is
how you use it
here we use this curly braces
again
here we are passing this underscore id
okay you have to provide underscore id
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar id whenever
you're trying to talk about code group
this is a compulsory field you need to
have it
after that
i'm using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing
and here we are using what
total marks
colon
here curly braces
again
dollar
sum
okay colon on which we have i want to
use it mark so i can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a javascript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now
section wide i'm able to get all the
marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of records
so hope you are clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
hope you are basically taking this
marks in my application
fine so
we are clear about how we are picking
that up but what in case if i would like
to take a marks for the specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but the only thing is
what will be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get
the all the section marks but if you
would like to bring it only for the
specific section we know it very well
what we need to do so here
before i talk about call dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar
match
okay and here
we are using this
uh option called section a
sorry
here
in dollar match we are giving this call
section
colon
here we're giving
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section you are able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay so
that's where exactly would like to
perform and there's another option like
in case if you would like to perform at
an average suppose if you want to
fetch the count of students in each
section and total marks
and average marks as well as so total
marks as well as the average marks we
want to get it so how are we able to
take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also into our code how we are
taking call group underscore id section
talking about section
total marks with this sum
we are also using this after that we can
also use the average
okay
so
this is we have taken
called group underscore id sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say sum marks
after that we can just put curly braces
and we can just use
count
okay
and
after this
we'll be using this colon
curly braces and use
dollar
sum
okay
colon one
okay and after that i'll put
comma here
and we use
average
and inside this average i will
use
in curly braces we can say
dollar
avg
okay
colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly braces is closed
okay so total how many
three curly braces will be closed
one square bracket and round brackets
and now you can see you got the average
markings
in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobile tv that
really create a difference of how
the
aggregation changes the way how you
react
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
aggregation it's time to talk about like
how
when it works with mobodb mobodb is
properly known for
i will say
for replication that is called high
availability and that feature comes by
default with mongodb you really don't
need to install any software for this
because it is a built-in feature for the
mongodb
so when you download that it
comes along with this so no additional
uh configuration setup is really
required when it comes to the mongodb
part okay so let's get started and talk
about how mobo db
can offer the replication see the idea
behind the replication is what
the idea behind the application is like
you are replicating it
okay
so when you talk about replication you
are replicating your data to where the
multiple child so here in mobile db we
have one concept available
okay that is known as call master
okay
and
slaves
okay master is one and there will be
multiple slaves
okay so these slaves where your records
are actually stored
and this is a master which will be
responsible to replicate the data to all
its childs when the request comes due to
that
in case if one particular
node
fails so automatically the data will be
taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and not slave process so to make this
possible to be a very simple option
available
in mongodb we have one concept like
called mongodb atlas so there we can go
and get our cluster ready so here we
start with the concept name called [ __ ]
db atlas
let's search for mobile db atlas and
here i see mobile db atlas database as a
service see this is a free
tool it's the cloud environment where
you really don't need to install mobo db
in your local machine it is a
cloud-based mongodb support which is
free to use with a limited amount of
space but yes for the testing purpose it
is the best suitable so i can start with
the start free or else i can say the
login here
okay from there onwards i can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is the place from where you can
start working on your cluster
see as i've told you like initially when
you will be working on this
mobile tv it will ask you
to create a cluster
initially
okay since i already have a cluster with
me
okay so
i really don't need to create it and as
a free
tier it will not
allow me to have more than one cluster
setup ready so if i say create a new
cluster
okay and i say
by default aws
okay and let me close on this
notification aws you can select any
other cloud provider and
8gblam cloud backup cluster name you can
see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour
reason being because i already have a
cluster with me
hence more than one cluster is not
allowed in a free tier cluster so i have
to cancel this
but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default aws
select your location
okay give the name of the cluster you
want to give anything you can give it
here otherwise let it be the by default
name cluster and say create cluster it
will take a while minimum two to three
minutes depends on
the availability it creates a cluster
for you
and your cluster once it is ready it
looks like that
okay so
here in this application you have to go
back and understand what is there in a
crystal when you click on cluster zero
you can see now
here we have a got
three nodes available one is called
primary node which is called master as i
suggested earlier
and now we have a call slaves
automatically when the clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary two will be
secondary
based on your package whichever you have
taken it you can increase the number of
nodes later on but as a free i'm gonna
get or i will be receiving total number
of three nodes available here
so records whichever will be stored
it will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary nodes and from the primary
i can insert the record and secondaries
i can read the records remember you
can't insert the records into the
secondary so you can only insert a
record only in your primary record
secondaries are not allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you no today well no data
available no data available
nothing is there because i haven't
stored any records as such
so i just go back to my cluster
so initially
i would like to go back and
create few things now okay i would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the clusters
because when a cluster is created clear
now so in that point of time no setting
is configured you have to do few
settings now
first setting is you have to put it
remember the steps
first step will be your network access
so in network access you have to go and
you have to say add ip address
and in this ad ip address you have to
select this option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those ip addresses will be white
listed
otherwise what you can do you can see
here in my options i have given
0.0.0 that means all ip addresses are
acceptable
so all ip addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third-party
locations
next you have to talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user there are
already some new users are created but
it is recommended that you to go and
create a new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user
so by default it is username and
password is given
so you can go back and create a new user
when i say add user
you can give
the username as well as the password as
per your own convenience so new user i'm
going to create it is called sl
okay
user
and here we're giving call
admin
123
so sl user admin 123
remember this will be the username and
password i'm saying add user
new user is automatically added sl user
and we went to three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement okay network access database
access it will ask you
like you want to create a new database
so i just go back to my project zero
will be on an option called collections
you have to go back and create a new
collection here
now it is retrieving the list of
databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there mrdp is one of the
database which is there
demo db is there a lot many databases
are there so you can go back and create
some new database and connect through
so i just create database i already have
a simply learn db with me
user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a databasing correction is
very easy if i give you the quick demo i
say create database
give the collection name called
sl demo
okay and give the username call
amp
slw employee i say create
now you can see slw create it is there
with me
so there is no record right now
and once it is there ready so remember
sl demo
and employee i'll go back to my uh
code again project zero
and from here i can say connect
because i want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there
so you want to connect it through so to
connect it through here very simple
option available you can just click on
this
connect option multiple options are
there through mobile share connect your
third party application of the mongodb
compass
so since i already have a [ __ ] shell
with me
so mac os i have this mac os with me
so you can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since i have this mac
os
i'm selecting this line
but i need to replace with this
you can see this username
okay
and you have to give the username here
well i'll selected this i open my
terminal
okay and this is i'm just closing this
and opening up
another terminal here
since i want to connect to the [ __ ]
shell now
so what i need to do here in this
i'll just paste that
the command which i have it now
username is
you remember i told you
you call
some users which you have already
created
let's check
here
sl user
i
say
that's a user
i hit enter
it will ask me the password so i've
given the password admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me
to this particular
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your shard cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly i have
it with me
so i'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there if i just want to go
back and say show
show collections
so i can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so
it's up to you now
by default collection which is their
employee so i can say db
dot
employee dot
insert
and now here we can just add
name
okay
now you can see
some exception is raised
so
you understand
now you can see the records are added
into my primary cluster so if i just go
back and
go back to my project zero where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
sl demo
employee
loading the documents
it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly
you see
the records will be stored
okay
so that's where exactly it works fine
for all of you
so we have this record
okay so when i say
show collection so we have a call
employee
and i say dv dot
employee dot
fine
so i can see we have got new collection
name called
this is added right now
okay so like this you have got
the first connection established and the
records has been inserted
hey guys
this is anova from simply learn it's a
pleasure to welcome you all in this
exciting video in today's session we are
going to learn about express js but
before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and
press the bell icon so you will never
miss any update from simply learn
let's begin and see what's in it for you
first we'll get an idea about express.js
after that we'll see what is express js
then we'll see the need for express js
after that we'll see the features of
express js moving ahead we'll see the
advantages and disadvantages of express
js
and then we'll see the companies that
are using express.js
nodejs is a far javascript runtime
environment but it does not support
request handling functions http methods
or serving files
so express.js comes into the picture
express makes the node.js code easier
as express provides a wide range of
features to develop both web and mobile
applications it is used to build single
page multi-page and hybrid page web
applications as express is written in
javascript it is very easy to understand
for the developers who know javascript
until now express is the most popular
framework of node.js
you must have heard about main stack in
web development right
where e stands for express.js
it is a backend part of mean stack
it manages routing http method sessions
error handling etc
let's see what express js is express js
is a node.js framework designed to build
api's web applications cross platform
mobile apps
quickly and easily
it is very high performance
fast
lightweight and unopenated that is there
is no structural way to write a code
express does not force you to write a
code in a fixed manner
express.js is used as a server-side
scripting language
let's see the need for js but before
that let me give you an example
if you have to write a rest api using
the core modules of node.js and the same
using the framework express.js you will
realize that with the help of express it
will take five to ten times less code
and time
that was the reason behind creating
express js framework for nodejs
express js is time efficient
fast money efficient
very easy to learn and asynchronous
let's see the features of express.js
for server side development with the
features of node.js xps saves a lot of
time
middleware middleware is a request
handler that has access to the
applications request respond cycle
routing this refers to how an
application's endpoints urls respond to
client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
dynamic content on the web pages by
creating html templates on the server
debugging express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
let's see the advantages of express.js
express is unopenated and we can
customize it and use it as per our needs
as it is written in javascript a single
language is used for front-end and
backend development
express is fast to link it with
databases like mysql mongodb etc
let's see the disadvantages the
disadvantage of xps.js is that there is
no structural way to organize things
sometimes the code becomes
non-understandable
there are so many issues with callbacks
the error messages that will come are
very challenging to understand
now we'll see the companies that are
using express.js
the major companies are ibm uber ebay
paypal accenture fox sports netflix
linkedin
expertthenlip.com there are more than 34
300 companies that are using express js
now
i think you guys have a brief idea about
express as it is a lightweight framework
that gives functionalities to make
node.js easy
expressjs is trending so much because it
is helping so many developers to save
their time it is so awesome that most of
the companies are moving towards it
if you know javascript and node.js the
framework expresses what you should know
to strengthen your coding skills hey
everyone welcome to this video by simply
learn this is anu health and in this
video we will see how to install express
js on windows machine but before we
begin if you haven't subscribed to our
channel already make sure to hit the
subscribe button and press the bell icon
so you will never miss any update from
simply learn
so without further ado let's begin first
we need to download node.js because
express is a framework of node.js
so without installing node
we cannot run express in my system i
have already installed node.js
you can search for node.js
node.js
now here
you'll find downloads
you can download node from here
and install it
but if you find any difficulties
downloading node.js you can click on the
link in the right corner to see how to
download node.js
now let's see the version for node to
verify here i am using visual studio
code you can go and search it and simply
download vs code
after opening your visual studio code
it will look like this
here
you will find a terminal click on it
the terminal window will open
here we will write
node
hyphen b
this will show us the latest version of
node.js
now we need to update the npm which is
node packet manager this bundle consists
of all the repositories and packages
required for development purposes to do
that
npm install npm globally
nvm
install
npm
hyphen
globally
this will download all the npm packages
globally now let's create express
for that first we need to create a
separate folder where we will keep all
the modules and files of express.js
let's clean this
pls
you can open the terminal by clicking on
the shortcut also by pressing control
and backtick
that will open the terminal for you
let's make a folder
mkdir
this is a command that is used to create
a folder on the terminal
then we will write our file name i will
write express
by
simply learn
enter
here you can see the file name expressed
by simply name has been created
you can also click here
and enter your file name
m.js
press enter
as you can see a new file has been
created
now we need to install a package manager
that is npm
we will write a npm command
open your terminal again
write a command
npm
init
enter
enter
version enter description and
description you can write express
tutorial
by
simply learn enter
enter
enter
hit repository if you have your git
repository you can add yours enter
enter
author
you learn
license enter
press yes
after this
you can see npm created a json file
now we will finally install express.js
we will write
npm
install
express
enter
now as you can see our express is
installed in our system
let's open the app.js that we have
created earlier
now
we will create a express application
with the help of express functions
that we can do by requiring the express
modules let's create our first program
first
constant
express
require
express
in this line we are requiring the
express module
const
and name equals to
function
express
dot get
to get the file
request response
to get the request and the response
of the user
function
we will need to pass callback function
here
let's write
response send
this message
will be shown
in the server
welcome
to
welcome to simply learn
now here
we will write a port number where the
message will be shown to us
at dot lesson
4 000
you can write anything
here also
we are passing the callback function
console.log
in console.log we will see the message
in the console
listening to port
number 4000
close this line
save this
let's run it open your terminal new
terminal
now to run this file
we need to go to the express
folder
cd
express
by
simply learn
we are now in a simply learn folder
now
easiest way is to write the file name
write
node space
the file name app.js
enter
now
you can see it is printing our message
listening to port 4000
now we will see a message on the server
open your chrome
type
localhost 4000
press enter
and here we go
a message is successfully displayed
welcome to simply learn hey everyone
welcome back to another video by simply
learn this is anubhav and in this video
we will be learning about rest api but
before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and
press the bell icon so you will never
miss any update from simply learn
so without further ado let's begin and
see what's in it for you
first we will see the introduction to
rest api
after that
we will see what is express js
moving ahead we will see what is rest
api and then we will see http request
types and in last we will create a
simple restful api from scratch
rest api are the standard way to send
and receive data for web services
client sends a request which goes to the
rest api
then to the database
to get or put the data
after that it will come back to the rest
api and then to the client
using an api is just like using a
website in a browser but instead
clicking on the buttons we write code to
request data from the server
it is very flexible and can handle
multiple types of requests
restful api is very popular and very
commonly used to create apis for
web-based applications
what is express js
express js is a node.js framework
designed to build api's web applications
and cross-platform mobile applications
it is used as a server-side scripting
language
expressjs is high performance fast
lightweight and unopenated
we'll see what is rest api but before
that what is rest and what is api
rest means
representational state transfer
rest is a popular architecture which is
used to create web services
now
api is a application programming
interface it is a code that allows two
software programs to communicate with
each other
rest api is a software that allows two
applications to communicate with each
other with the help of internet and
various devices
now
we will see the http request types
first one is get it is used to request
data from the server but mainly this
method is used to read data
next one is
it is used to update the data or to
change or replace it
next is
post
post method is used to create new or to
edit already existing data
after that it is delete
delete method is used to delete the data
completely from the server
now we will see the complete
architecture of http request type
in this
client sends a request in the form of
json file
and with the help of http request
which are get patch post and delete it
will go to the server
and then
sends back the response to the client in
the form of message
to tell what happened to the request
and now
we will create a simple restful api from
scratch
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
first
you need to open your editor for this i
am using vs code
for this
you need to open
your
folder
created one folder in the
c drive
express chairs
for this
you need to have node.js installed
first
open your terminal by clicking on
terminal new terminal
first
we'll write npm
init hyphen y
press enter
this will create a json file
for us
now let's install express.js
for that
we'll write npm
install
express
press enter
installing express js
this will add
all the dependencies
now we have only one express installed
we need a file here
to write our code
so we'll create a file called
index
dot js
enter
in this file we will write all our code
open index.jsjs
first we'll write
cons
app
file
express
in this line we have imported the
express package
which itself is a function
so we'll write parentheses here
to initialize it
now
write
writing 4000 here
this will call a variable
which is 4000
i will write
dot lesson
till now
our api hasn't defined any endpoints
this app.listen tells the server to
listen on specific port
which we have defined already as a
variable
4000 now
in app.listen
we will write a second argument as
callback to tell us the api is working
or not
then we'll write
board
comma
we'll write the callback function here
right factor function
console
dot
log
backtick
it's
running
on
http
local host
police
and
port
which will come under curly braces
now
we can run this app by writing the
command on a terminal
first save this file
terminal
now we'll write a command
to run this file
index
node file name
index.js
so it's successfully showing us it's
running on http port
4000.
folks in your
chrome or anything
i'm using chrome here i'll write
localhost
4000
enter
closed enter
can't get
now
if you open this url
you will see
this message
can't get this is because we don't have
any api endpoints as of now
but express js is still responsing with
error message
you can add an api and call it hey
everyone welcome back to another video
by simply learn this is anubhav and in
this video we will be learning about
error handling in express js but before
we begin if you haven't subscribed to
our channel already make sure to hit
subscribe button and press the bell icon
so you will never miss any update from
simply learn so without further ado
let's begin and see what's in it for you
first
we'll see what is error handling
after that we'll see how does error
handling works in express.js and then we
will be setting up error handling in
express.js
so
what is error handling
error handling is a process in which
express catches and processes the error
that occurs synchronously and
asynchronously
express comes with its own default error
handlers
simply
in error handling the tasks are to
identify errors report them to the users
and then
develop some recovery strategies and
implement them to handle the errors
this whole process should not slow the
overall processing time of the program
now
how does error handling works in
express.js
expressjs comes in with a built-in error
handler
this default error handling middleware
function is added at the end of the
middleware function stack
it automatically catches all errors in
router handlers and allow developers to
extend router handling functionalities
by middleware function
error handling in express is done using
middleware
this middleware is defined in the same
way as other middleware functions the
error handling functions have four
arguments error request response and
next
we have next function method
that matches us to the next middleware
handler in middleware
in error handling we have the next error
method this function skips all
middleware and matches us to the next
error handler for the router
now let's setup our error handling with
express
open your visual studio code
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
first we will create a new directory
for that
open your terminal
new terminal
let's write
make directory
now i will enter the directory name
i will write
simply learn
or i can also write
error
press enter
you can see
the error and link directory has been
created it's empty
let's go inside that
cd
see the error handling
now we are in the link folder
now let's create a new project here
we'll write npm
in it
hash
by
so
as you can see
the json file has been created in the
error handling folder
now
we will install couple of packages here
okay
first we will install express
write npm
install
express
now we will also
install morgan
which locks the request
after that we'll also install http
errors
errors
this package makes it very easy to check
the status code
and in last
we will install node dot
env
press enter
this will take couple of seconds
now
in the dependencies
you can see dot env express http errors
and morgan
now i will create a file in this error
handling folder
write
app.js
enter
now
let's install nodebond which helps us
not to reset our file again and again
for that we'll write in the
npm
install
minus sign
save
node mod
enter
this will also take couple of seconds
now
here you can see
the node one has been successfully
installed
now open your package.json file
here
in packet.json file
you can see here
this line
i will rewrite this
you can also remove it let's write
script
and in this
i will write
note mon
tab
dot js
yes
save this file by pressing ctrl s
yes
now
open the file
app.js
here
we will be importing some packages
in node.js we use require function right
so
we'll write const
express
required
and
express
here we need express packages
now we will be needing morgan
we will write const
organ
required
then
now
like this we will need http packages
const
error
create
error
required
http
errors
we also need dot env packages to import
our environment variables
for that we will simply write required
square
tactic
dot
enb
dot
config
for this command we need a env file we
will create a file
dot
enb
printer
and here we have our env file where we
can have our environment variables
first we want a port for this
application so we will write the port
port
3000
save this file
now
again go back to the app.js file
here
first we will be initializing our app
we'll write
const
app
express function
now we will start the application for
this we will write
const
port
to which it will be called
process
dot emb
dot
port
3000
now we will make our application listen
to port 3000 we will write
app
dot lesson
port number
port
it will call the port number
and here
we will call the callback function
header function
and here we will make our log statement
for this we'll write console
dot log
server
is
running
on
port
dollar sign
and
both
now
let me start the application before that
will save this file
now to start the application we'll write
npm
start
enter
here
it is showing error let's find out
okay
here
here i have wrote script
here we need to write start
save this file
and now clear this screen
enter npm
start
so as you can see it is successfully
running in the port 3000 hello everyone
welcome back to another video by simply
learn this is anubhav and in this video
we will be learning about react and
express deals but before we begin if you
haven't subscribed to our channel
already make sure to hit the subscribe
button and press the bell icon so you'll
never miss any update from simply learn
so without further ado let's begin and
see what's in it for you
first we'll get an idea about react and
express js after that we will see what
is react.js then we'll see the features
of react.js moving ahead we will be
learning about express js and its
features
and in last we will see how to connect
client side to the server side
every application consists of front end
backend and the database together they
form full stack and in this video we
will be talking about react and
express.js
react was created by meta and it is used
to make web application responsive
express js is annotated and it is used
to make apis express is maintained by
node.js
let's see what is react.js
react is a javascript library which is
used to build mobile in web applications
fast and interactive
it is an open source
reusable components based front end
library of javascript
basically with the help of react we can
create a client-side application or user
interface
it is a combination of html and
javascript
let's see the features of react.js
first jsx
it is syntax extension of javascript
with the help of react.js we can use the
extension to see how the ui should look
like
virtual document object model
dom it defines how document are exist
and manipulated in the web page
performance there are several ways to
speed up your exact application by using
virtual dom
way data binding information flows in
one direction react receive information
through arguments and pass it by
returning values
react goes beyond simple ui and has many
extensions for complete application
support
extended with flux and redux among
others
debugging
it is a small browser extension to make
debugging easier and faster let's see
what is express.js
express is a node.js framework designed
to build apis web applications cross
platform mobile apps quickly and easy it
is very high performance fast
lightweight and unopenated expressjs is
used as a server-side scripting language
let's see the features of express.js
first
fast server-side development with the
features of node.js express saves a lot
of time
middleware middleware is a request
handler that has access to the
application request response cycle
routing
this refers to how an applications
endpoint urls respond to client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
dynamic content on the web pages by
creating html templates on the server
debugging express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
now we'll see how to connect client side
to the server side
first we need to create a folder i have
created a folder named react express
let's see
go to your c file
here i have created react express folder
now we will be using a text editor in
this video i will be using visual studio
code let's open it
then
we will add all the npm packages and
create a react application called client
open terminal
new terminal
let's write some command
npx
hit
react
app
client
enter
this will take some time until then
just wait
yes so it's downloaded
now as you can see the client folder has
been created
with all the npm files
in this client folder you will see all
the npm files node modules
json file also
yeah
now
we'll go to this folder
cd
client
now to get this application running type
npm
start
this command will start and compile this
application
now
it has opened a web page localhost 3000
this is the first client-side
application startup page
this will be now working as a client
now
let's create a back-end application for
that
first
clean this terminal
let's open a new terminal
type
npx
express
engine
data
folder name
press enter
okay
now
this will take some time to install
press yes why
as you can see a api folder has been
created
now we'll go to that api folder
cd
api
enter now we are in the api folder
let's install
all the packages in pm
install
press
enter
this will again download all the
packages
so npm has installed all the packages
required to run this
as you can see in the packages
packages.json file there are all the
repositories and files
that i used
now let's terminate this terminal
terminal
now let's go to the client folder
cd
client
press enter
now we are in the client folder npm
this command will start and compile this
application
now
we'll see the standard express
application that has got installed
will again go to the terminal
delete this terminal
create a new terminal
and this will go to the api folder
npm
start
this will start the terminal
press enter
now
we'll go to the chrome
local host 3000
refresh it
you will see the standard express
application that has got installed
and today's session we are going to
focus on the objectives of why would you
want to use react.js as a technology to
build scalable web applications in
today's session we will also focus on
the component based design strategy
around react.js and
how the strategy focuses on reusability
of building single page applications
which are lightweight quickly loadable
with reduced amount of waiting and
response time for customers that would
be accessing your web application
in today's session let's start with
understanding the objectives of what
we're going to focus on purely we will
start with what react.js is all about
we'll then get into discussing the
features of react.js we'll then move on
to the components that make up the core
structure of react.js we'll discuss the
various type of components we'll then
move on to understanding props effective
state management event handling and we
would close the session with event
binding so what is react.js all about
it's a trending technology that
everyone's speaking about based on
scripting and it evolves around this new
age term called full stack web
development that we would do in today's
digital world so react.js is basically a
javascript based library for building
fast and interactive user applications
for the web as well as for mobility
devices so it is basically a rad or a
rapid application development tool that
will assist with quickly setting up a
pattern based application that's
disciplined that's flexible to change
that's well designed so that any changes
coming from your customer can be
incorporated very easily and the changes
can be isolated to one small section of
the code hence reducing the effort that
would be required to go ahead and
rebuild and test the entire application
again for every change that comes in via
the customers request it's again an open
source technology being based on
javascript the very fact that it creates
a set of components makes them reusable
which means that you can inject these
components on the page as and when
required and that really promotes the
reusability of the application in the
design uh react.js is also basically
maintained by facebook
and that is also what makes it really
popular amongst developers let's explore
some of the core features of this
technology the first concept that we're
going to speak about or the first
feature that we're going to speak about
focuses around jsx which is a syntax
extension to javascript it is basically
used with react to describe what the
user interface should look like so by
using the jsx or the syntax extension it
is now possible to write html structures
in the same file that also go and
contain the javascript code but still
ensuring the right level of segregation
between
the script and the html in order to keep
the code legible maintainable and
flexible to change the other important
aspect of react.js is the virtual dom
the generic dom is released by w3c and
is an api that allows us to create dhtml
pages react keeps a lightweight
representation of the real dom which it
calls the virtual dom which actually
wraps the w3c dom api or the dom tree
structure that exists on your html page
so manipulating the real term is much
slower than actually manipulating the
virtual dom which is the wrapper layer
on which the react.js api operates so
when the state of an object changes the
virtual dom changes only that object in
the real dom instead of updating all the
objects and this saves a lot of time
because rather than actually going and
generating a full tree shake and
recreating the entire dom tree structure
of the page working at the virtual dom
has this added benefit that react.js
comes with where it does not need to do
a complete dom tree rewrite for any
update that dynamically you would want
to do on the page the architecture that
react.js uses in a model view controller
based architecture react sits at the
view which is now responsible for how
the application looks and feel in an mbc
architecture the controller will map to
the functional flow of the application
and the model will map data store or the
data mapping mechanism in your app while
the view works and maps to the html
templates that are rendered on the
screen so mvc is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
into three layers the model which looks
at the focuses on the data and the data
mapping the entity model the view which
focuses on the html templates and the
controller that maps to the functional
flow of that use case so the model would
relate to the data the view to the ui
and the controller acts as a super user
and allows us to transmit data between
the model and the view this makes data
binding a very crucial feature of
react.js and reacts one way data binding
keeps everything modular and fast so
once you have your data set up in the
model you obviously would want to take
that data and represent it inside the
view so this unidirectional data flow in
react would mean that when designing a
react app you would often nest child
components within parent components to
ensure you have a healthy and an
intelligent data sharing strategy so i
could have a shopping cart component
which would have a list of line items
within it and that would be an example
of a nested component sharing data and
information among themselves next comes
the extensions so react goes beyond
simple ui and has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support these extensions also would
provide server-side rendering and
support mobile app development and hence
react can also be extended with flux and
redux among other third-party extension
apis that support this entire ecosystem
so the very fact that we today built
using the javascript language is because
we can go ahead and create hybrid
applications that can then also be
ported uh as installable apps on
mobility platforms the debugging for
react is extremely easy to do because
of the large developer community and
support with plugins and facebook also
provides a small browser extension that
makes debugging for react applications
faster and easier to do coming to the
components which is the core
aspect of what react has to offer
and it's very essential that we build
the right component designed in the
application to ensure that transmitting
data and the information flow between
various components is really smooth in
terms of its execution and it's well
designed and this is the crux of the
single page application that we designed
today where you really do not navigate
the user to different pages but you just
inject a set of components into the page
and remove them when not required
creating an illusion for the end user
that the customer is actually going and
navigating across different pages so
coming to components they are actually
the building blocks of a react
application that represent a part of the
user interface so if you look at the
facebook website itself this would be
split up into different components so
there would be a login component that
would take care of the credential
management there would be another
component that looks at registering
users the company logo and
the connect and share that you see would
also be a different set of components
that could be injected as and when
required onto the page so the sign up
the image component the icon component
all of these are split into several
small sections of code blocks which can
be tested separately and then added onto
your consolidated page so the components
basically promote reusability where a
component that is used in one area of
the application can also be reused in
another area with updated data and this
is what actually helps speed up the
entire development process in react you
can also nest components within the each
other for example in a e-commerce
application with a retail store i could
have a shopping list component that
could further have an i a set of
products within it and a product
component could actually further nest a
product detail component inside it and
this is what and how the entire
application structure can be designed
with nested components the render method
is one of the most important
and it is
in its minimal form basically a
component uh must define this method
which actually specifies how this
component would go and render onto the
dom tree and ultimately the browser from
passing properties between components
which is again a very core aspect of
react where components would communicate
with each other by transmitting data in
terms of properties and a component can
also receive props and these are
basically data points or data values
that are passed by the parent to specify
certain values from the parent to the
child component components are further
categorized into certain categories that
we are going to talk about so there are
stateless functional components and
stateful class components now what do
these mean we'd focus on the state list
first now these are javascript functions
which basically return a stream of html
and they can be contained in a js or a
jsx extensions files then we've got
stateful class components now these are
regular classes that extend the
component class and they must contain a
render method that should return a
stream of html and again they can be
contained within a gs or jsx file so a
stateless functional component would not
really hold any state in terms of data
values and will just return a static
stream of html on the other hand a
stateful class would also do state
management by storing some amount of
data along with it and then bind that
into the
html view which would be rendered on the
ui let's talk about props or properties
now components can pass properties from
the parent component to the nested or
the inner child component properties
actually help making components more
dynamic because due to the data binding
and the state that the properties hold
you can actually flash certain amount of
updated values into the user interface
or the components that are being
injected onto the ui it sends important
to define all these props their data
types and also their default values
props in a component cannot be changed
let's talk about state management next
which is the value that most of the
components would hold at any given point
of time when your application is
functional we are back again to the
facebook landing page where we see the
login component and let's consider a
scenario here where when a user logging
into facebook clicks on the login icon
without entering any credentials so what
would happen obviously the login would
fail and the color of the login icon
changes and a sudden alert symbol
appears instructing the user to perform
a different action and prompting the
user to first register into facebook
before attempting to login because
that's not a valid user id that probably
would be registered with facebook now
these actions are facilitated by react
with the help of states and that is what
makes uh state management
a very crucial aspect of the react
framework so a state object stores the
values of properties belonging to a
component so if i have a login component
the current state of that component
could be successfully logged in or
denied login these would be different
valid states for a property belonging to
a component so this state can be
modified based on some user action or
based on some network changes so every
time the state of some data changes
react would re-render the component into
the browser the state object is
initialized in the constructor of the
component which is a function that
automatically triggers when the
component is object is initialized the
state object can also store multiple
properties so multiple property values
can be assigned and this dot set state
is a method used to change the value of
the state object the set state function
performs a shallow merge between the new
state that you provide and the previous
state let's talk about event handling
now events are going to be the
notification or triggers or user
performed actions that would trigger the
state in a component to get modified so
every application revolves around
handling and listening to events in
order to do something else in response
so in response to an event you can
perform an action so event handling with
react follows two major conventions
reactive ends are named using camel
casing rather than lower case so camel
casing would have the first letter of
the word in lowercase and the second
major letter in uppercase with gsx you
can pass a function as the event handler
rather than a string so entire function
expression can be passed as a parameter
to the event handler and not just flat
string values so here if you look at the
code you see an html button on the click
of a button that's the camel casing for
the on click registration equal to we've
passed a function which is called
display message which will be executed
when the button is clicked and that
display message plays the role of an
event handler now it's time to
understand event binding so along with
the notifications that you subscribe to
so that you would come to know where
users have clicked or what interaction
has happened in your component you may
also want to send data or information
along with this event so event binding
tells the browser which function is
called when a particular event occurs
and what kind of data you would want to
send across so event binding in is
basically what you achieve in react
using these following steps the first
step is you would find the handler in
the render method by using a keyword
called as this so this is a system
defined keyword in react which is used
to bind the event handler inside your
render method the arrow functions in the
render method can also be used to do
event binding the arrow function is now
an ecmascript standard which also makes
it a javascript standard and hence
the arrow function is very similar to
the lambda operators etcetera that you
have in other programming languages like
c sharp so binding the event handler in
the constructor is also another step or
another mode by which the event binding
can be achieved the arrow function as a
class property can also be implemented
to do the binding let's move to a
hands-on demo to understand how do we
set up a basic application using
components using nested components using
props or properties understanding state
management and doing event binding and
event subscription to set up a simple
react.js application so let's start with
uh creating a simple demo on react.js
and we're going to create a simple
application
that will connect to an online music
streaming service called spotify and we
will call our application music app so
let's get started the first step is to
first get the node.js platform and
server installed to do that let me go to
google and let's just type node.js
and here is the website
nodejs.org there are two versions
available the lts which is the stable
version and the current we'll prefer the
stable so we'll click on that and you
can see we have an option which is
called save file the moment this file is
saved to the disk we just need to double
click on it and keep clicking on the
next button to get it installed on our
system and we also have a documentation
available here so which explains most of
the features of the node platform and
there are binaries available for
different os's mac windows etc so you
can select the right bitness 32-bit
64-bit and the right os and then go
ahead and download the specific uh
version that suits
your platform and you can see here that
there are different there are also help
files available that will allow you to
go through the installation documents
for node.js installation on linux etc so
to start with
i'm opening up the command prompt and
here is where we are going to call the
node package manager using the node
package manager which is pre-installed
with your standard node.js
installation we will initialize our
react application so we would say react
dash app and we want to now go and
create an application called music app
in this folder so as a prerequisite for
the demo all we need to do is install
node.js from node.js.org the official
website just download it and install it
and that's when you open the command
prompt you fire npm which stands for
note package manager in it for
initialize uh react dash app is a
standard keyword to
initialize and create a skeletal
structure of a react.js application and
the name of the app is music app so
we'll hit enter we'll give this some
time and you can see it's
started downloading the core
react.js libraries and it is attempting
to create
our application so it's installing all
the prerequisite packages and scripts
that are required initialize and create
a new react.js application called music
app now once this application is created
all we would require is an online editor
so you could use an offline or an
on-premise editor as well so any editor
of your choice it could be atom or
sublime text or webstorm and for this
demo we're going to use visual studio
code which is
a free editor available by microsoft and
you can just google for visual studio
code again this is not visual studio
professional edition etc that we use for
building our c-sharp or mvc based
applications this is a lightweight
editor for building javascript based
footstep full applications so so while
this installs let's go and take a look
at
visual studio code so this is the visual
studio code editor and this is the
editor that we've
installed directly downloaded from uh
visualstudiocode.com
and installed it and all we need to do
is open up this folder that would be
created with all the prerequisite files
in it we just say file open folder and
we would open that folder within our
visual studio code editor so we'll give
it a while until that application gets
generated and once it's created we will
again implement the component based
design and architecture and the data
flow between the components and we also
look at connecting to a live data source
which is a json set of characters that
we would consume which is a restful
service the set of music tracks exposed
as a restful api endpoint by spotify
which is a premium streaming service we
will connect to that and we will look at
accessing some of the music tracks on
that website okay so we've got
the application created here so let's
minimize this and
we'll open up our editor all we've got
to say is file and open folder and
let me go to the react.js demo folder so
this is the music app that got created
and that's exactly what we're going to
open up here so we'll navigate to
that folder it's called music app we'll
select it
and have it opened in our application so
you can see here we've got a note
modules folder this has all of the
pre-installed packages that make up the
react.js library we've got a folder
called public which will have the
index.html file that's the root file
that will launch so this is the single
page application that we typically
create uh in react you have a single
page which on which we're going to load
multiple components so that's the
index.html and then we could go and
create
a folder structure currently if i open
the source folder we can see a single
app.js file and that basically is
the file that has uh the source code in
javascript for a single component which
we are interested in adding on to our
page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding css file uh and
then we've got
the a public folder with the index.html
file which is going to be
the root html file that launches
when we run our application so let's uh
go right up here and let's add
a link to an additional file so i'm
going to link to another style sheet
okay so we say relationship is equal to
stylesheet and the type is going to be
text
and css
and
we will reference a file called
reset
dot css and this is a file that we look
at
adding up later on it doesn't exist at
this point in time so we will connect
this and that's purely for styling
purposes
so that we can have
all of our css styles defined there next
thing i'll right click on the public
folder we'll create a new file we'll
name this file as reset dot css so
that's going to be the css file that
will have all of the css
styling that we're going to apply and
i'm going to use a ready code snippet
for the css code so let me just uh okay
so i'll all i'll do is uh i'll just go
and pick up
a ready css file that i can just go and
use uh if you look here i have a set of
uh
css files that are created that we're
just going to use uh
within our application and
and that will avoid us spending a lot of
time on the styling so that we can focus
on our core concepts uh which is
actually learning how component based
architecture works and how do we set up
components and have data communication
between them in react so uh here is a
file called
reset.css let me just fire up
notepad and i'll just open up this file
copy up the text here and i'm going to
just paste it within
my reset.css and if you look at the code
very simple it's all about
styling so we've got uh article aside
etc all html5 tags setup as display
block so they take up the entire width
of the page we've got some padding
margin and font size etc defined we've
removed list styling for the unordered
and ordered list specifying the line
height for the body tag so basically uh
just styling up tables and uh so nothing
nothing to do with react here it's just
about simple uh css that we've added up
uh and now we need to actually go in and
dive into create creation of the
components that we need so let's right
click uh on the source folder so i'll
select the source folder we'll right
click there and that's where we're going
to create a new folder which is called
components okay so this is the
components folder now that's going to
hold
all of the components within it uh
within the components folder let me
create uh another new folder and i'm
going to call it app and this is exactly
how we are expected to structure all of
the code that we have now i already have
a css and app.js which are the root
components that were added by default
and all i'm going to do is i'm going to
move them within this folder called app
okay so there's a proper segregation of
responsibility and
all of the code that
deals with a particular component is all
added into respective folders and this
really improves the maintainability of
the application uh going forward now we
need some images
and i'm just going to make use of some
set of images that i've downloaded from
the web and
here are the set of images that i have
so i'm just going to copy all of them
and we'll come to a music app and we'll
go into the components and app folder
and that's where we're going to add all
of the files and you've seen all of
those image files getting added so these
are just icons and images we're going to
use for our music tracks inside our
application now uh let's move to the
app.css file and uh
this is where we've actually got uh
so the app.css file is the file that's
going to style up
the
all of the style rules that we've added
into the root app component and
this is what we'll have to revamp so
i'll just get rid of this code and
we'll probably add something for the
body tag the html tag and the root
element let me say hash root and let's
set the height to a hundred percent
coming to all of the html across the
page we'll give it a font size of 10
pixels
and
the h1 elements
let me give it a padding of
0.77
and 0 let's set
a background color give it a background
color and just select
some random color here that can be
applied then we'll set up the text
alignment which is going to be the
center of the page we'll set up the font
family the font family is
and this is part of uh sun serif what
else do we add let's add up the font
size 1.88
and also the color so again uh these are
standard uh html and css elements so
nothing really that
has to be done that is specific to
react here so again we are bringing in
the highlight class so there is a class
called highlight that we will create
later in the
html view of this component and we'll
set this to a red rgb component so
combination of 46 113 and 238 okay so
that's uh pretty much done let's move on
and also add up for the anchor tag let's
add up some text decoration and set it
to none so that the anchor tags don't
come up with those underlines and of
course we'll provide a color of hash
okay so a white color there now coming
to the h2 element for the h2 element
let's have font family and again i'm
going to use
so i'm going to use
the font family that we defined here
bracket and we change this to probably
1.55 okay now coming to the app tag
let me just save this and create a copy
of it uh there was some content that
i did delete and
i can simply go and make use of it so
i've just undone all of the deletion so
this is uh something that i can't
if i can use something i can just
probably use it from the tag below so
let me start with the height here and
let's say the height of the header is
100 of the app sorry not header padding
0 17
10
17
the background and i'm going to change
that to background url so the background
url or let's say the background image
will have a url property okay and that
url is going to be dot slash
pg1 dot jpeg so that's the image that
we've added some in the previous step
let's also add
backgrounds size so we'll add background
size and set it to cover i'll also need
a background position that will center
let's have background repeat which is
set to
no repeat so that we don't have the
image
in a grid format uh and then i would
need this bit of it let's take up the
font family we'll maintain the same font
family let's use font weight the font
weight is going to be 500 and the color
is going to be hash
so that's a white color then we come to
dot
app.playlist so that's going to be
another class that we are going to use
dot but app dash playlist is what we
we're going to name it and
let me say that the display should be
flex
flexible display and we will justify the
content to leave spaces
in between all right so that finishes
that bit and now uh
let's write up a media query for the
responsiveness of this page so this is
media for only screen and
max width is going to be one zero two
zero pixels okay and the class name that
we'll provide later is obviously app
playlist so for this screen size we
would align all the items
to the center and we change the flex
direction okay so we seem to be good
with
the css for the app as of now and that's
the app.css
that we created let me save everything
okay let's check
for any kind of
additional so all free of errors no
errors now things are good in the app
css and it's time to move to the next
step of building this application uh now
we'll have to go and add up
the code for uh the app.js file so let's
dive into the app.js file and this is
where
we will actually need to go and add
all of the code that is required for the
app component so all the code that's
relevant to
the app component we are going to add up
inside this specific component itself
which is going to be obviously the
app.js file so we have skeletal code
which is import importing the react
library and uh let me get rid of the
basic sample logo we'll have app.css
that's getting imported here uh besides
that a lot of other files that we'll
have to get in so
let me import playlist and this is these
are the components that we'll create
as we go forward and
we're going to get this from the
playlist folder
and the component the file is going to
be called playlist so we'll add that
then we'll have to go and also import
search bar so what we're basically doing
is we're going to split this app into
different components there's going to be
one component that's manages the
playlist of all the tracks
one component will
act as the search bar so that's the
search bar component that we're going to
add so searching for tracks will be
managed by this we'll have another
component that we'll create that will
get imported into the root app component
which is a search results so this is
going to display the record set with the
set of results as an outcome of the
search criteria so search results slash
search results and finally we'll go and
import spotify that's the spotify
service from so we'll create a utility
folder which will hold
the code that connects us to spotify so
that's what we are adding up next so all
of the imports are done one component
that manages the search bar so that
search bar search results let me correct
the spellings there that search results
that spotify and playlist so that's done
now let's move on to the class that
we're going to create here so let's
create a class app that goes and extends
react dot component so that's going to
be a react.js component so that's a
constructor we discussed about props or
properties and state management and
that's what we are implementing
we are using the super keyword as a best
practice so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor and also
we pass the values up the chain to the
super class which is the root component
class now we're going to initialize
a variable called state that's going to
manage the state
and we are interested in tracking our
search results so we'll have multiple
results so we'll show that as an array
the playlist would have different names
so we'll just call ours new playlist
that's the default name and we will also
store a list of tracks which is going to
be playlist tracks so playlist tracks is
going to be a list of tracks and let's
close
this block okay and this two is going to
be initialized within the constructor so
we'll add it here and now we need to do
the binding we discussed uh data binding
so let's look at
creating a search variable which will
hold this dot search dot bind and bind
to the context of this very class so we
are passing this pointer then we will
create
another variable called add track which
to this dot add track dot bind and all
this functionality is what we're going
to add going forward so right now we're
just setting up the bindings then we'll
have capability to remove a track so
we'll say remove track so remove track
equal to this dot remove track dot bind
and let's fix that so and all of these
two is going to be initialized as part
of the constructor so that's where we're
going to add it then we need to update
update the playlist name so we need
functionality that will help us to
update the name of the playlist so
functionality that helps us to update
the playlist name so this dot update
playlist
name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind and this
is the pointer that we'll pass i need to
save the playlist so this dot
save playlist
equal to this dot save playlist dot find
and pass this and then i would also need
to remove the track that has been
searched for from the playlist so remove
track search go to this dot
okay remove track search and
dot find
and finally one last function that
executes
all of these which probably will bind to
point to this context so all the
declarations are done in the constructor
now we need to provide the definitions
for all the methods that we actually
have added here so let me select this
tab inside and let's start with the
search function so we'll define the
search first it takes
some variable value that it searches on
and then i'm going to say spotify dot
search i'm going to search for term dot
then and that's an observable so the
moment it the search returns a value it
it's going to call this
callback function and that's when we
want to set the state and we're going to
set the state for search results to
whatever is passed by the system so the
search results are going to be returned
as a callback and that's what we store
as an updated state now coming to the
add track method so let's scroll up and
we'll say add track and this will take
the track to be added let's declare a
temporary variable called tracks equal
to this dot the current state of all the
tracks that are there in the playlist
now if track start find i'm going to
call the find method so if we are able
to find which means that the track is
already there in the playlist then we
would not want to add it if it's not
there in the playlist that's when we
would want to go and add it the triple
equal to is an equality operator that
will check for both a watch value match
and a match on the data type as well
okay so if the track is already saved to
nothing if the track is not safe just
track the track id because that is the
track that will uh have to be added if
it's not if it's already there then just
return if it's not there then we've got
to go to this variable called tracks
we'll use the javascript method called
push and we will push the current track
into this tracks
array and then update the state so we
want to set the state of the playlist
tracks and this is how uh your state
management that we discussed in detail
is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now let's talk about the
remove track so that's the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove so let's let tracks equal
to this dot state dot playlist tracks
those the set of current tracks that we
have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to tracks
dot filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is not equal to the
track dot id which means this particular
track is
not there in the list
okay so you need to remove that and
again i have a method called as unshift
which will actually get rid of the track
in the array and then we've got to so
we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of search results and
then we are going to say tracks equal to
tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id not p
equal to the track dot id and then this
is where we would want to say this dot
set
state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making the change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track
is now the remove track and the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it removes
the track from the search criteria so
the search component which is managing
searching of the tracks it will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined operation
we want to execute then i've got update
playlist name which will take the name
of the track to update and this dot set
state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so
here we let me create a constant
variable constants are variables whose
values will not frequently change we'll
take all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot uri so
we actually want to go and now save this
on a spotify so that's the reason we'll
access
spotify's safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist name that we
want to create on spotify will be called
new playlist so that's the custom
name that i want to provide and the
playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps from a
maintainability perspective so even
though everything is in the same file
it's well classified and differentiated
into different code blocks so we'll add
the anchor tag and we'd say href is http
localhost so that's the default server
port on which this application will run
okay and we want to give it a custom url
name of music file so the h1 terminates
will then say div class name equal to
app within that this is how we're going
to inject a search bar that's going to
be the search bar component injected
here and on search so that's the custom
event we will call a method called
search so on search we just call we bind
to a method called this dot search then
we'll open up another div here we'll
have class name equal to app dash
playlist and if you remember that's
exactly the css
class name that we refer to in the css
file we have another component called
search results
that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
uh
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the 2ds function and it will remove it
from the search results text box then we
have another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks will be
bound to this dot state dot playlist
tracks okay so on the top if you look
here we started with defining all the
function declarations in the constructor
then we provided the function
definitions okay that's how and this
that we passed refers to the context of
the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things we'll have
to do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have remove functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etc that you
provide
in other programming languages so that's
done we've created our app component now
let's create another folder under
components and we've got to define all
our various components here this folder
is going to be
for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add
two files within it the search bar dot
css okay and another file that we need
here is
search bar dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be
6.94 rpm and
margin
bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.88
0 the border should be 1 pixel solid
white the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge to give
a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll set up
the border radius then we've got
margin bottom so we've got a bottom
margin
that we want to add up then we have
color so let's add up the color c3f so
that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be so
if someone focuses so focus is the got
focus so if someone clicks inside so the
end user goes and clicks inside the text
box
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button
the cursor will set it to pointer so
that's the cursor pointer the width we
set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash 1 db954
that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got uh our font
family let's set up the font family to
the same standard font 80
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size
to 0.833
rem correct this
and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic uh
css properties so that will add a slight
uh transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up
let's also provide a border here so we
remove
in fact let's remove the border we would
not want a border on the button that
would look odd so i'll get rid of the
border and color we'll specify
as per our standard color that we've
been using okay so that's the color
we've specified and then i've got font
weight of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case if we hover around
the button we would want
the background color to change so it
will appear to have a slight little glow
there a mouse pointer moves over the
button okay so that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes uh
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and
get the code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search bar first thing let's go and
import
react from
react next thing we would want to do is
import
the search bar
dot
css file then we define a class called
search bar which extends
react dot
component we define our constructor and
we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we'll just need one variable
here which is the term to search for in
the search bar and then let's say this
dot
we'll define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot
search so that's the search function and
we'll have it bind to this
then we've got this dot handle
enter so the moment we enter into that
search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot
set state and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get
the value that is there inside that text
box the moment the search term the user
is entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update
the local property props dot on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which uh we're also
going to pass the system define event
keyword so if there's any data flowing
along with the event we are interested
in it in this case the data is the key
code that the user is pressing and if it
is 13 that indicates that's the ascii
key code for the enter button so if the
enter is hit then the user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where
we write our render method that's going
to render the html view and we return
the complete view here so that's the
view now that we want to return let's
say diff class name equal to search bar
then on the input text box
we will use placeholder equal to enter
song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change
on the on change event the moment the
term changes we connect that to handle
term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i'll have to put up
here so in the render function uh we're
going to return a value i shouldn't
forget to export the search bar okay so
that's uh what i want to export so we've
exported that okay so at the end of this
uh what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i am going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we are going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close the button back
within the pattern tag search so that
completes the
the render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions
that we
had actually written
so two things we've completed now
in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks removing
tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core uh concept when
you're working with react where you
would actually have every separate
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is
the track component that will manage
individual tracks so a new folder a new
file called track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us
so let's start with dot track we would
say display is flex
align items
center border bottom 1 pixel solid rgba
256
256
256 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes uh when we write up the
html view we'll add a padding here of
0.5 we'll set up a font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s
border of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgba
000 color hash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265 2 6 5 5 is the last
parameter so that's the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that
for all the h3 tags nested inside that
we need a margin bottom of 0.22
finally let's have track information and
paragraph tag we'll have the font size
of
0.83 rem and a font weight of 300 and a
color as well that we'll add so let's
add up a color here rgba 2 6 256
256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css and let's move to the
track and we'll move into the javascript
file so let's move into so let me take
what we added in the search bar i'll go
to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this
and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh
this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props dot on add this dot props dot
track and then we have the remove track
so that's going to be the remove track
function this function is not required
so this dot props dot on remove and this
is the track that we would want to go
and remove we'll add up another function
called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is
remove if this dot props dot is removal
so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added via
this render action function and this dot
remove track is what it's going to map
to
let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track and
we will terminate this here so now the
render action uh let's also have the
return here and we just add up the
button and this is going to add track so
you can look at how the component is
completely dynamic uh in nature so we
have two buttons that are going to be
added this button with the hyphen is
going to remove the track this button uh
with a plus sign is going to add the
track and you can actually see how
simply it was done in a render action
function so the render action function
actually helped
with
checking that if
on the value of the props
and if the user
depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
uh
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div here
is going to be
track dash information within it we'll
add h3 we'll bind to this dot props dot
track dot name so the name of the track
is going to get bound here then in the
paragraph we will find to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot album so that's what uh we've data
bound to
and then let me add an iframe and iframe
allows us to very easily inject some
content into the page within a small
embedded window the source parameter of
the frame is going to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash
embed slash track and close this so
that's the spotify stream that we're
going to connect to and this dot props
dot track dot id so that's the track id
the width is going to be 300 the height
parameter this the height parameter is
going to be 80 of the iframe and
the frame border is going to be 0 and
the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method uh which will actually
give us plus minus button to add and
remove a
new element okay and that's
what we can actually go and add up there
so let's check now whether uh all that
we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good
in terms of the track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track list
css
and it's going to have
track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much
so let's just say track list and we just
provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need uh in the css so
let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we
also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks individual tracks
so we want to get this from track slash
track and we'll define class track list
which is going to go and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list and we'll bind to this dot props
dot tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return
the track component which is going to
bind to individual track data the key is
going to be track dot id
so the key is going to be
track dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on add defined so that's
what we'll connect to we add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove will do this
dot prop start on remove so that's for
the track removal and
so we've got our track list
uh oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export so we'll
have to go and export the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track lists and let's move on
to the next component now so we've got
app which is root we've got the search
bar that takes care of entering the
search criteria we've got individual
tracks that are searched and returned
and we've got a track list that manages
a set of track records so the track is
more relevant to the playlist and then
we've got the search results also to
manage once we search for some set of
tracks so we'll add a new folder which
manages search results and this is going
to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we'll say search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels
we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is zero
point
rem background color will be rgba
95
23 23 0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of zero for pixels to pixels to
pixels ash
and then
let's add
a scroll bar so webkit
and mozad are the constants specific to
mozilla and
chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with
two zero pixels
in that case dot search results
with is ninety percent
with a margin bottom of two are even
okay so we're going to add the hyphen so
it's hyphen webkit scroll bar zero pixel
width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with uh the css i need to get
to the
js file now let's move to the search
results
js file and that's where we will now
have to go and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list
add it up here this will be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get a
track list
this will be track list
and
i'm just going to return class name will
also be search results so that's the
component and this is going to export
out search results so it's accessible
across
other components then we've got h2 with
results let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props
dot search results and on the on add we
are going to bind to this dot props dot
on add so we already have that so that
basically completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that
we will have a playlist dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need
to add up to the playlist and i'm just
going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's uh just a css
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css uh let me get uh
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it
out here we'll make some small changes
this is going to be
playlist i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get uh the
constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props
dot on name change that's when we'll say
event dot
target
dot value so we get the updated playlist
name coming to the render we now need
the input
input
is going to be on change equal to
this dot
handle name change
the default
value
we have already provided with a
hard-coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got
track list so track list is
what i will add the tracks i'm going to
bind to this dot props dot playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
tracks
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll bind that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist
dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on
save and here we're going to say save to
spotify so that's with uh
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list now
we need to uh do a quick lookup
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in uh and create
an id it takes us to our dashboard uh
that's where we can create a sample
application
the name of the application will be
musico file okay and
we'll say that we are building uh some
kind of desktop app for example for
which we want to uh connect this to and
we'll also need to provide uh so we'll
say next
refresh the dashboard so it's uh
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique so i'll just copy that up let me
come up to my application under the
source folder i'm going to add a new
folder called util and under that a new
file called spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at the source of that as we go
through the demo the next variable that
we'll create is the redirect url or
let's call it redirect uri and that will
equate to localhost colon 3000 which is
the port and we'll create another
variable called the access token let's
also create another constant variable
called spotify and this will work like a
function expression so we'll equate it
to a function called get access token
and we will say if access token is true
then return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot href dot
match
and we will say this is equal to access
token which will be equal to and we will
give a regex expression to do a pattern
match ampersand so that we can actually
get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence
the pattern match is crucial here
another constant
variable called
expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another edge x
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case
the access token should be equal to
access token match of one then we create
a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say window dot
set timeout and we're going to say
access token equal to comma expires in
multiplied by thousand then we will say
window dot history dot push state and we
will say access token we pass the second
parameter as null the last parameter as
slash
and close this and we will return access
token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist
dash
modify so we're actually building the
url that will now get generated so we'll
say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant
access token equal to spotify dot get
access token so we get a reference to
the same access token return we call the
fetch function and we're going to pass
https
api dot
com
spotify.com
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the pairer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response
and then we will say
return response dot json after that
another then block so we'll now say json
response
and if
not
json response dot tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return json response dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as
a variable with a lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary json object
with id and that's where we want to
associate track dot id that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artist of zero dot name the
album is going to be track dot album dot
name and the uri we will equate track
dot url so that completes uh this block
will open the next and we this will be
the save playlist which will take the
name and the track uris and here we will
check if not
name or
not track uris dot len in that case we
simply return out of the code and then
we declare a constant variable called
access token which will be equal to
spotify dot get access token so we get a
reference to the access token we then
declare headers authorization bearer is
going to be taller access token and
we'll create a user id and now we will
return the fetch result where we will
pass https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers will
be the header information then we call
the then function declare response as a
variable use the lambda expression and
access response dot json we use the then
block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to
jsonresponse.id and then we return fetch
https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1
slash users slash dollar of user id
slash playlist so this is how we've
constructed the urls manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as host so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and as the body
we will say
json.stringify to convert this parameter
name and then we will generate
a response variable to
response.json and then we'll create
jsonresponse with the lambda operation
we'll create a constant playlist id
which is equal to json response dot id
we will return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers variable be constant headers and
this
goes here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and the
body is going to be json dot stringify
uris track uris and we close this we
close this block we close this block and
we close this block so that completes
our code of course one more thing we'll
have to do which is export this class
out so export default spotify and that
completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
here is
the client id that we'll have to exactly
match so i'll copy this client id and
provide it here so that's the client id
that we actually need and we could also
store it
out here
so that's the
client id and that's the redirect url
that we've also defined there and we
just create an access token if your
access token is true we return access
token so the access token is something
that we are going to do a match from
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist and i've got search so
these are the two functions which will
go and connect to the spotify service
by using this client id
and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and
bring out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i'm just going to
search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us
a confirmation link the moment we tried
to connect and execute our application
uh that's proof enough that it actually
went and connected to the
service there and tried to return a
value to us so this is what we did we
just added an artist we said search and
you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
uh if i go back to my dashboard of my
music file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully connected out here now i'll
have to login to so this was the
development app that we actually created
on the developers portal of spotify now
we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist that just got added right and
there were four songs that i'd actually
added to the playlist and you can see
here those four songs have got added out
here okay so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist uh the playlist has
got generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
that we successfully created with this
react app and the core concept of the
react app was breaking it down into
components which is the search component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks uh then we created the
search results which will generate a
list of results which further contains a
track list and this is the embedded
iframe which gave us the response which
is scrollable here and you can see that
the iframes we created allowed us to
scroll this uh with this embedded web
page inside the iframe container so with
that
i hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be implemented on
the page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole in today's
session we'll deep dive into node.js
framework and we'll discuss each and
everything that you need to master this
framework we'll start this topic by
discussing what is node.js and how you
can install node.js in your laptop or
desktop and will end with the interviews
questions that are frequently asked in
the node.js interviews so watch the
video till the end if you haven't
already subscribed to our channel please
do so so that you never miss an update
welcome to this video by simply learn in
today's session we're going to learn all
about node.js so without further ado
let's begin and look at what's in store
for us first up we'll understand what
exactly node.js is then we understand
the necessity of node.js then we'll
learn about some of the parts of node.js
node.js express framework node.js use
cases and finally we'll look at some of
the industry trends so what exactly is
node.js now consider a scenario where a
user interacts with the web application
the user only interacts with the front
end of the application but there's a lot
of work that goes behind the scenes
now in a web application there's a front
end a server and a database the front
end is developed using javascript and
frameworks like angular and react while
the server is built on java php or
node.js and the backend database that
stores the data usually consists of
mysql or mongodb so node.js is an open
source cross-platform javascript runtime
environment for running server-side
applications it is used to develop io
intensive web applications like video
streaming sites single-page applications
online chatting applications and other
web applications it is used by large
established companies and newly minted
startups node.js was developed by ryan
dal in 2009 and at the same time of this
session its latest version is v13.3.0
now that we know what nodejs is let's go
ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development here are a few points first
up node.js is extremely fast being built
on google chrome's v8 javascript engine
its library is extremely fast in code
execution
note package manager has around 50 000
bundles for developers so whatever
functionality is required for an
application can be easily imported from
npm all apis of node.js library are
asynchronous that is non-blocking it
means a node.js based server never waits
for an api to return data node.js
dramatically reduces the processing time
while uploading video and audio files
it is also an open source platform and
is easy for beginners for web
development the above reasons more than
justified the popularity of node.js
platform and why it is being adopted by
large number of organizations and
businesses today so now moving on let's
familiarize ourselves with the parts of
node.js node.js consists of several
components now let's look at them one by
one first up we have modules now modules
are like javascript libraries which are
used in a node.js application to include
a set of functions now we can use
required function with the parenthesis
to include a module in a nodejs
application node.js application has many
modules to provide basic functionality
needed for a web application some of
them could be http util fs url query
string stream and zlip next up we have
console the console module provides a
simple debugging console that is similar
to the javascript console mechanism
provided by web browsers now the console
can print messages to std out that
prints standard output messages and scdr
to print the error messages the next
component is cluster now node.js is
built upon the concept of single
threading programming a single instance
of node.js runs in a single thread to
take advantage of multi-core systems the
user will sometimes want to launch a
cluster of node.js processes to handle
the load a cluster can be added to an
application in this way here's a small
code for you the next component is
global now global objects in node.js are
available in all modules now these
objects are functions modules strings
etc some node.js global objects are
mentioned in the table you have dir name
that is the directory name file name
exports module and require the next
component is error handling now node.js
applications experience four types of
errors we have the standard javascript
errors system errors user specific
errors and assertion errors now errors
in node.js are handled through
exceptions now for example let's handle
an error that would occur when we divide
a number by 0. now this error would
crash the node.js application and so we
should handle this error here's a small
code for you
next up we have streaming a stream is an
abstract interface for working with
streaming data in node.js streams are
objects that let you read data or write
data continuously there are four types
of streams first one is the readable
these are the types of streams from
which data can be read writable these
are the types of streams to which data
can be written
duplex these are both readable and
writable streams
lastly we have transform these streams
can manipulate the data while it is
being read or written moving on to the
next component buffer the javascript
language has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data an
empty buffer of length 10 can be created
by this method next up we have domain
domains provide a way to handle
different io operations as a single
group domain module intercepts errors
that remain unhandled there are two
types of methods that are used for
intercepting these errors firstly we
have internal binding in this case the
error emitter executes its code inside
the error method next up is the external
binding now here the error emitter is
explicitly added to a domain via its add
method the next component is the dns the
dns module enables name resolution for
example it is used to look up the ip
addresses of host names dns module is
used to connect to a dns server and
perform name resolution by using the
method dns.resolve the dns module is
also used for performing name resolution
without a network communication by using
the method dns.lookup the next component
is the debugger node.js includes an out
of process debugging utility accessible
via a v8 inspector and built-in
debugging client
this node.js debugger is not feature
packed but supports simple inspection of
code it can be used in the terminal by
using the inspect keyword before the
name of the javascript file in order to
inspect a file say myscript.js you can
use the following method
now that we are familiar with all the
major parts of node.js let's go ahead
and learn about the node.js express
framework
express is a flexible node.js web
application framework that provides a
wide set of features to develop both web
and mobile applications you can assume
express as a layer built on top of the
node.js that helps manage the server and
the roots now let's have a quick look at
some of the core features of express
framework it is used to design single
page multi-page and hybrid web
applications it allows setting up of
middleware to respond to http requests
it defines a routing table that is used
to perform different actions based on
the http method and url it also allows
dynamic rendering of html pages based on
passing arguments to templates now
moving on let's take a quick example of
a simple hello world program now this is
developed using express framework to
gain a better understanding all right
first up we have the word express now
this is used to import express framework
into our node.js application now the
app.get method is a callback function
with parameters request and response the
request object represents the http
request and has properties for the
request query string parameters body
http headers etc the response object
represents the http response that an
express app sends when it gets an http
request now the application will listen
to the defined port which in this case
is 8081 and variables host and port will
contain the address and the port
respectively lastly we have the
console.log which is used to show the
address and port in the command prompt
so this is what the command prompt would
look like and finally the output is
displayed on the web browser having
learned about the express framework now
let's move on and look at the node.js
use cases
now it is no doubt that node stands out
for its speed and intensive data
exchange so top industry leaders like
nasa paypal netflix among others
incorporate node.js first up we have
netflix the world's leading internet
television network with over 117 million
users is one of the top companies that
trusted their services to node.js the
reasons why the company chose to use
node.js were application scalability and
data intensive application now you must
be wondering what application
scalability is this basically the
potential of an application to grow in
time being able to efficiently handle
more and more requests per minute and
data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream netflix
simultaneously next up is walmart now
walmart is the world's largest company
by revenue with around 514 billion us
dollars according to the fortune global
500 list in 2019. again the reasons why
the company chose node.js were
asynchronous i o and efficient handling
of concurrent requests now asynchronous
io which is a form of input output
processing allows other processing to
continue before the transmission has
finished nodejs is able to efficiently
handle concurrent requests with the use
of thread pool and event queues uber
uber is an american multinational
ride-hailing company offering services
that include peer-to-peer ride sharing
ride service hailing and food delivery
the reasons why the company chose nodejs
were asynchronous io quick iterations
and active open source community as
mentioned earlier asynchronous io
permits other processing to continue
before the transmission has finished now
quick iterations now nodejs is
continually being updated and added new
features that help in further
improvement in the performance of web
servers and finally active open source
community resolves many problems that an
organization may face in a particular
scenario next up we have nasa now nasa
is an independent agency of the united
states federal government responsible
for the civilian space program as well
as aeronautics and aerospace research
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were reduced access times
handling of data intensive tasks and the
fact that the servers are active 24 7.
now nasa has lots and lots of data and
using node.js has really helped them in
reducing the access times it is also
continuously handling and working with
large streams of data node.js is highly
stable which helps in keeping the server
active 24 7. next up we have paypal now
paypal is an american company operating
a worldwide online payment system that
supports online money transfers as
opposed to traditional methods like
checks and money orders the reasons why
the company chose to use node.js was the
fact that node.js has extremely fast
bill times it allows tasks to be carried
out with fewer lines of code when
compared to other server technologies
like java and php and nodejs being data
intensive efficiently handles a large
amount of data next up is medium medium
is a popular online publishing platform
developed by evan williams and launched
in august 2012. the main reasons why the
company chose to use node.js were a
data-driven applications now these
applications are ideal for being
interfaced with node.js servers b to run
a b tests now a b testing is essentially
an experiment where two or more variants
of a page are shown to users at random
and statistical analysis is used to
determine which variation performs
better lastly node.js server maintenance
is simpler than its counterparts moving
on to the last topic of this session
industry trends now node.js developers
are in demand across the globe since
many companies are adopting javascript
libraries according to forbes it is one
of the top 10 most in demand jobs
according to note source the total
number of node.js downloads increased by
40 percent in the last one year the use
of node.js in production has increased
dramatically since its release in 2010
with early adopters such as linkedin
paypal and netflix among others node.js
has seen an exponential increase in its
use in web development the popularity of
node.js is also accounted to javascript
now since javascript is the most popular
language as evident from a survey
conducted by stack overflow in 2019 many
developers can start working on node.js
library with not much of a learning
curve node.js developers are being
offered better salary options than other
web technology developers according to
pay scale the average salary of a
node.js developer in india is around 6
lakhs 13 000 rupees per year the average
salary of a node.js developer across the
united states is around 105 000 us
dollars per year in this video we'll
help you install node.js on your windows
system so without further ado let's
begin the first thing you need to do is
download node.js from their official
website
so go ahead and type
download
node.js
navigate to their official website
and here
you can see the 64-bit version so go
ahead and download that once the
download is done go ahead and run the
downloaded node.js installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finished the
installation process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification now this process ensures
that node has been properly installed
to do so we first open the command
prompt and then type in a few commands
to verify the successful installation we
type in this command
node hyphen v now this command returns
the version and if it returns the
version it means it has been
successfully installed
so here we go it returns the latest
version
now the final step is to update the node
package manager now this npm is bundled
with node.js which consists of all the
repositories and packages required for
development purposes
so to do that type in the command
npm
install
npm
hyphen hyphen
global now that we're done with the
installation of node let's go ahead and
implement a small program for that we
make use of a text editor in our case
we've installed vs code so go ahead and
download vs code once you're done with
the installation this is what vs code
looks like so go ahead and click on file
and create a new file it's going to be a
simple program where you're going to
print a hello world message on the web
browser to do that we make use of http
modules so node comes with built-in http
modules to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first say
var
http
equals required
and just say http within single quotes
now the http module can create an http
server that listens to the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method
so let's go ahead and type the code
say http
dot create
server and internally it consists of a
function
now the parameters to this function are
request and response now the response is
basically used to write to the client so
we say response dot write and here we
type in the message say hello world
welcome
to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message by default it
listens to the port number 8080. so we
keep that as it is and we end it save
your file
say
demo.js maybe demo1.js and say save now
to run the program you have to open the
command prompt so open your command
prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop on the desktop
so cd
desktop and now to run it say node
demo1 dot js now you navigate to your
browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go
our message is successfully displayed
today we're going to jump into node.js
on the architecture around node.js
so why would you want to get involved
with working with node.js well there's
actually a lot of great reasons a lot of
the top web applications that you are
working on today are built with nodejs
and the architecture beneath it allows
you to not only just build those web
applications but to be able to build
in-class applications and by enclaves we
mean microservice driven applications or
applications that are running on uh your
phone on your desktop on your tablets
they can all be built with nodejs
and there are huge advantages around
working with node.js so one of the
biggest ones being the huge community
around node.js node.js is just one of
those standard solutions that you use
for building out your core architecture
when you're building out an application
and there's just a lot of people out
there that are using it
so let's jump into web applications and
how it'd be of benefit to you with your
web solutions
so
with node.js you have the client side
and the server side and the client side
has the solutions that allow you to have
hooks into the client side put together
very easily
so behind the scenes of the client you
have service and technology and
connections to your database so if
you're building out your solutions with
node.js it makes it very easy to be able
to architect the entire solution from
top to bottom for your entire
environment whether you're building that
locally on a test server whether you're
building for a traditional data center
or if you're working in the cloud so on
the client you're going to be using
technology such as react.js and angular
in the server you're going to be using
node.js php and java and then the
database itself is going to be something
like mysql or mongodb
and actually the number of databases
that can be supported with node.js is
increasing all the time
so when you're working with writing your
code in angular or react.js you can even
use vue that's actually a great one
working with node.js
you have this client-side framework that
provides the hook into the web browser
whether it's a mobile web browser or a
desktop web browser
the server is then responsible for
taking those requests that are coming
from the browser and
interpreting them and so on the server
you're going to run node.js you're going
to run it alongside with php and java
php if you're not familiar is a really
great way to get started with writing
web applications that run on the server
java is just a really solid traditional
application language for building out
web apps
and then the reserver itself is going to
be responsible for those client
interactions with back-end services
connecting with apis and reinforcing
your security model now can you do all
of that in the client yes you can do a
lot of that in the client particularly
with the frameworks from angular and vue
they are really flexible you can do some
great things there but one of the things
you want to be looking at when you're
working with building your web
application is really three key things
one is security the second is being able
to scale your solutions and the third is
speed and responsiveness and what i have
found through my own architecture is
that if i balance out between clients
and server the load and the structuring
of how you actually build those
solutions it really helps
create a very seamless solution to your
customer
and then at the back of all of this you
have your database and my sequel a
mongodb of two popular databases but you
can also use node.js to connect to many
of the clouds databases that are running
on aws azure google cloud ibm other
services they all have connectors in
fire node.js into their databases
so let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why it's so
good
so to begin with node.js has what's
called a single threaded event loop
architecture and this allows you to be
able to handle
many many concurrent clients at the same
time it's just a very flexible way of
being able to scale up your support for
many
clients and then in addition to that we
have the javascript event based model
along with the javascript callback
mechanism that allows you to have this
standard approach to being able to
connect with and talk and discuss
interactions between the client and the
server
it's good to have these kind of
standards where you're not using
something that's unique to a specific
framework or a specific technology this
just makes it so it's a more accessible
for everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself everything centers it
around the the concept of the event loop
and the event loop has a an event queue
an operation completed and fire requests
threaded pull and then it'll actually do
the actual computation or the file
system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless loop the great thing again with
node.js is that it's not new technology
it's been around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are
running node.js
so let's now dig into each of the parts
of the node.js architecture so let's
talk about requests
so the way that the request works is
that you have your framework
such as angular on the client and that
will then send a request to the web
server there's many ways that those
requests can happen through web workers
through forms and through other
interactions
but at some point a request is sent to
the server
and so these requests can be for data
they can be for deleting data they can
be for updating data they can be for
interacting with services as mentioned
before but the goal is to have some kind
of request now once that request
actually hits the server and then we
start actually getting into the cueing
and threading process that centers
around the event loop and this is where
node.js really excels because it's able
to use a single threaded model to be
able to manage from just even a few
requests to tens of millions of requests
so it receives the actual uh request and
starts the event queue and this is where
a single threading process starts is by
cueing everything up appropriately
and then it then maintains the threads
within a pool so you have the cueing
process as one action and then you have
a threaded pull which manages those um
threads as well
and then we have an event loop which you
know goes through actually receives and
processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually going to be interacting
with a system and that could be a
database it could be a cloud system it
could be an api file system but we're
interacting with something that's
outside of the node.js server so the
node.js server itself is doing some
actions on the server but then it's also
interact with things outside of its own
server environment
and so let's talk a little bit about
that workflow
so requests come in they go into the
event queue and they get spiraled
through the event loop and then we have
a non-blocking operators which are going
to be doing the input output polling
such as kq epoll and other services and
from there we're also going to be then
interacting with a threaded pool and
we're using the blocking operations to
manage that threaded pull
and that threaded pole is going to now
then go outside of the server and
interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system or api or microservice these
are things that can be interacted with
and so let's go through some of these
advantages that we have here so so i'm a
fan of working with node.js so i have
lots of advantages so the one the big
ones are right off the bat is the
ability to be able to handle multiple
client requests
quickly and easily this really is
important as we move into our digital
ecosystems and we start scaling up
solutions you'll find that as you build
successful apps the demand for those
apps will grow exponentially and what
that means is you need to be able to
have a solution that can interact with
requests quickly and easily there's no
need to create multiple threads because
of the event loop again this is another
thing that's really critical when it
comes to building out solutions you want
to be able to have a solution that can
scale massively at the flip of a switch
now particularly as we start working on
building out cloud-based solutions
nodejs also utilizes really low
resources and memory again when it may
seem like a small thing when you have a
solution and it's using just a maybe a
smaller amount of memory but if that
solution keeps adding to that memory
usage you then restricted for how big
that application can grow so the less
resources and memory a solution is using
the faster and higher it can grow in
scale
and we're going to be going through net
working with nodejs and node package
manager today
so let's go through why you'd want to
sit through this tutorial and what
you're going to learn well first of all
we're going to talk about the node.js
modules and wide node jsb and modulus
architecture is of benefit and how you
can leverage that
then we're going to talk about what node
package manager is and how you can use
it with the modular architecture
why you'd want to use npm
how we actually go through and do the
installation of npm it's actually pretty
easy so you should be able to jump on
that really quickly
then we'll actually go ahead and
actually go through the details of what
it takes to create a package.json file
with npm
and finally we'll do a live demo we'll
actually step through using terminal
window to actually interact and build
out an npm package
so let's get started
let's talk about node.js modules first
and understand the architecture and the
modular structure behind node.js so that
you understand why it's so important to
have npm
so let's talk a little bit about modules
so modules in node.js they provide the
functionality that you can use for your
applications of this actual architecture
of nodejs is built in such a way that it
allows you to be able to create
solutions and extensions very quickly
and easily
so it has many modules that require
additional functionality for different
applications
that you can customize and modify to
meet your needs
so some of the
most popular modules that you have for
node.js include express
js which is becoming an ever more
popular
back-end architecture for building out
solutions
we have react.js
which is from facebook
we have node daemon an open source
solution
and each of these modules are very big
solutions themselves but you can also
create smaller modules and that would be
of benefit to the types of applications
you're creating so you can kind of think
of modules in a sense as microservices
so that you can actually build out
solutions that you can re-share over and
over not quite the same but um similar
kind of thought process for actually how
you interact with them
so let's go through what npm is so npm
itself stands for the node package
manager
no
great shakes there as the name says it's
responsible for all the packages and
modules that are bundled within node.js
so the notepad manager itself really has
two key functionalities and the first is
that reply it is a central repository
for all packages and modules which you
can then search through online you can
go to search.nodejs.org
and you can find all of the packages and
modules that are out there
the second is that it's also a command
line or terminal
line utility that allows you to install
those packages so you can actually go
through and you can see the version
management and dependencies that within
those packages and you actually can
control the packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend the project you're working on
so when you're building out a project
one of the concepts i like to use is the
concept of lego bricks
big fan of lego and uh what's great
about lego bricks is that they're all
individually by themselves very small
very specific functionality um but if
you actually get a whole collection of
lego bricks together you can build like
crazy cool things so think of when
you're working with the node package
manager itself is that each of those
individual pieces that you're working
with um each of those individual
packages are their own lego bricks and
by themselves you can then edit and
update and maintain that piece um
separately from the whole environment as
long as your inputs and outputs then
really the piece where you snap the lego
in or when you connect lego to something
else
are interactive and open and well
documented then you can actually then
use those modules effectively throughout
your project
um so you can actually then be able to
you do that you can do version control
on your codes and dependencies you can
do testing very easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes i want to release
um a new module you can do that
effectively using npm and it will
actually go through and do the actual
deployment for you
so let's go through the npm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js
locally then you've already installed
the package manager but you can also
access it through command line or
terminal window on your your data server
or in your server farm or via the cloud
if you haven't now downloaded node.js
here's the website where you can go down
to install it and there's windows and
mac versions of that
code as well with the installers which
allow you to get up and going very
quickly
uh you want to be able to run the
installer and accept all the default
settings uh just um you know to begin
with you want to kind of have the
standard setup so that you are most
familiar with the normal settings before
you start getting to the point where
you're a master and you're tweaking
things
um there is a way that you can open up
the command window or the terminal
window
and once you've actually installed
node.js to verify that it's actually
installed you can write command node
dash dash version and i'll show them
pull out the version of node.js that you
have installed and then you'll be able
to see that you've got you're actually
up and running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm we can do apm dash dash version
and it actually will then show you which
version of the node package manager you
have running so you can actually take it
full advantage of that program and
verify that it's actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package so packages themselves are
actually just json files if you're new
to this space json file is a structured
file format uh that's based on
javascript it's a very xml like format
uh for being able to
write instructions for the actual
package itself and so the json file
forms the really kind of the the heart
of each package you create
um it has all of the metadata that you'd
have about a particular object
and then it provides a root directory to
any of the applications or modules
that the package may be referencing
in addition and it has any other
additional
information about the project that such
as dependencies and other files that
need to be included so here we have is
an example of a package that would be
created
using npm json script
and you can actually take this package
file as it is right here
and use the command npm in it and it'll
actually run this package and so you
would actually then have it a demo
application up and running really
quickly
uh you can then go ahead if you want to
you can edit any of these parameters so
like for instance if you wanted to
change the description or the version uh
or what is the the main index script
that would be written you know these are
all things that you can edit very
quickly and easily you can just use text
editor to make any of these edits
and so we have the different metadata
that can be updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo of working with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using npm and to do that
i've got three windows in front of me
right now so i have this window here
which is my terminal window
where i'll be doing all my instructions
then i also have a
folder which shows where i'll be putting
all of the files and then finally i'll
actually have a text editor in this case
i'm using vs code because it's free
but you can use any text editor you like
to be able to go in and show what the
coder that's been created
by npm in the json file so you can
actually see what it looks like
and then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create a
new project folder so i'm going to go in
i'm just going to move into
i'm going to do
change directory i'm going to
the project folder
and we'll see down here that we have an
empty project folder um but for this one
i'm actually going to go ahead and i'm
going to create a new directory in this
one and i'm going to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simplyland folder
and we are going to
move into the simplyland folder
and so we're now in the simplyland
folder uh there's nothing in there right
now um so the first thing we want to do
is we want to take uh go ahead and
initialize this folder as a project
folder for working with npm now to do
this you will have to already installed
npm if you have no js npm comes with it
and if you want to see whether or not
you have npm installed so you can just
do npm
version
and that will actually tell you
what the version of npm you have
installed is it also verifies that npm
is installed so i've gone ahead and i've
been able to validate that i have npm
installed so what i'm now going to go
ahead and do is i'm going to initialize
this folder so to do that just do npm
init and you'll see that the path is
that we're already in the simplyland
folder and then when you do that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name we're going to
go with the defaults for right now and i
can show you how we can edit those in a
little bit uh we're gonna go with just
say yes to all of these just by hitting
return
and you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder this is the
instructions that we have in the folder
do you want to go ahead and create this
we want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so we go ahead and open
this up with
vs code
here we are we can actually see what all
of the information is we can go ahead
and we can actually go and update
this metadata if we want to i'm going to
leave it as is for right now because i
want to show you a couple of other
things so a lot of times when you're
actually working
with npm and the reason why you're using
npm is that you want to take advantage
of packages that are freely available in
the open source community that are
supported by node.js and one of those is
a package called express and express is
a lightweight framework for building out
uh web applications similar concept uh
to angular or react.js
i like using it and it's also a great
way to be able to
show how we can
install this using npm so to install
this uh you just start with the command
npm and then you type install
and then we type the name of the package
we hit enter
and it goes ahead
and what you'll actually see
is a couple of things one is we have a
dependency in our package above
we also have
so this is in our json package that is
now a dependency it's written in there
we can also go in and under our node
modules we actually see that we have
we scroll down we should see express
there it is express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use um express we can actually just come
in and we can write command npm
uninstall
i can type
express
oops i did a typo there so let's try
that again npm
uninstall
express
and couple things going to happen one is
in our json file the dependency for the
express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under our node
modules there are no extensions there
so this is kind of cool this allows us
to be able to see
that we can
easily add and remove packages
so let's just go ahead and i'm going to
install express again so
install
express
oops
npm install express
all right so it's gone ahead and it's
installed express
now one of the things that often happen
is that when you're working with a
package the actual json
package so you'll receive uh this file
and you want to be able to go ahead and
install of the
sub modules that come with it so and you
can go through you can manually install
them like this or you can actually run
an install command so you can actually
install all of them at once i can just
show you what that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and
simulate as if we're going to install
bootstrap
which is another
popular framework
stream
and we're actually going to go with
and then we'll save that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there we
do have
express there it is right there
so we now come over to
our
new commands we can actually write the
command
npm install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm
install
okay it does help to save your file so
let's go ahead and
let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have is not just
express but
we'll also see that bootstrap has also
been added
now i don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that but it gives
you an idea of
what's happened here now if we want to
we can actually go in here and we can
see
on in
install
bootstrap
and it will actually remove that from
your json package so there we are that's
how you work with using npm from getting
started with a
setup for a base uh initialization of
your
package going through to creating the
first package
being able to set up and control the
naming convention for each of the items
within the metadata that provides the
instruction for
the package how you can put in
dependencies such as express and
bootstrap how you can install them and
remove them and actually use do all of
this through command line if you have
any questions yeah please let us know
and today we're going to talk about how
you take my sequel very popular open
source database and node.js a very
popular architecture for building up web
applications and pull the two of them
together and why you'd want to do that
so let's jump in
so first of all let's cover why you'd
want to go through this tutorial so
we're going to cover what my sequel is
we're also going to tell you how we're
going to connect with node.js and why
you'd want to do that with mysql and
then finally we're going to do a demo
taking you through all the steps on how
you can actually do that kind of
connection
so what is my sql well basically my sql
is probably the world's most popular
relational database and so if you think
of relational databases that are table
driven mysql is arguably the most
popular
database out there for rdbs systems it
is by far the most popular open source
relational database
the entire database is written in c and
c plus plus it's been around for a
really long time um again it's open
source which is great
which means that there are no licenses
or costs for actually using my sequel
and you'll find that companies of all
sizes from small mom and pop shops all
the way up to
massive enterprise global enterprises
are all using my sequel
so you know why would you want to then
take that next step of connecting
node.js with my sequel what
fundamentally comes down to the basics
of the differences between the two
products
mysql is database and node.js is a
architecture framework for building out
web applications
again with mysql it's open source it's
free to use you don't have to pay
anything there are no licenses which if
you compare it with other solutions out
there is a big deal
my sequel even though it is open source
it's incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature open source programs out
there i think apache is probably
arguably more apache ui web server it's
probably more mature but
my sequel is very close behind it so it
has had a huge amount of investment this
is not a solution that's only a couple
years old we're talking about a solution
that's more than 15 years old
very very structured very powerful and
you can do a lot of really good things
with it
you can actually then
build solutions with it and using php
java really any kind of database
even
other systems and other frameworks will
allow you to interact with mysql
and
it just allows you to work with just
huge amounts of data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and my sql
so we're going to go ahead and we're
going to get started by putting our
environment together so let's start by
selecting node.js and downloading it so
we'll go to nodejs.org
and there you have your options for
windows mac or if you want to go for the
source code you can go ahead and
download and install that
the next is to install zap and so i'm
going to go to
zap installers for a quick search and
it's on our apachefriends.org site and
here we have example windows linux and
mac os 10
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be our ide our
integrated development environment in
this instance we're going to use visual
student code if you don't use visual
studio code
it's a great free open source solution
for being able to build applications
i'm a big fan of it so i encourage you
to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio um code up and
running so go ahead and we can open up a
new folder
and let's go ahead and create a new
folder and just put a stratified desktop
here and it's just for
kicks and giggles so i'm going to type
in node mysql for our source code and we
open up that folder and select that
and so we now have this folder selected
in our visual studio code editor
and what we want to do is we want to
get rid of the welcome page and we don't
really need that anymore
and
we're going to terminal window so we're
going to see the
scripts that we're writing we're going
to be using tunnel quite a bit um in
this so for instance we're just going to
test that we have npm installed we do so
that's great
and we're going to go npm init and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the json file for that package
has been created
so we go in there we can see that all
the defaults are selected
now you'll see that index.js is the
default uh file that'll be created so
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to create our own index.js file and
we're going to add in some instructions
into that file to actually install the
correct software from the npn package
and the first thing we want to do is
install express
which is a package that's great for
building uh lightweight web applications
not mobile applications i suppose if
you're doing a responsive design
but in this it's really it's a web
application environment so we're going
to
put in
the requirements for that and then we're
going to also go and require that my sql
gets installed
and
[Music]
you'll see that for both of them we're
just going to use npm's default commands
for creating it and we'll go down to the
terminal window and we'll do npm install
and it's going to
install
the express and my sql environment
and as that installs you actually see on
the left hand side under
the folder you actually see
the files starting to be installed
so for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will be all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these commands make sure
everything is installed so we're going
to open up zamp which allows us to go in
and
view and see that everything in store so
we have my sequencer we have a patch
installed
we can start to stop under services
with zap go ahead and do that you can do
this through telnet window as well but
the
ui interface is really nice so let's go
into
my sql um interface
and you'll see that we don't have any
databases
these are all just the
standard test databases and so we have
to go ahead and create one
and so let's
get our
sql database connection created
so we're going to write
const
db equals mysql
create connection
and we want to create connect to
the localhost in this instance
and user is just going to be a
root user account
which is the standard user account that
comes from my sql there is no password
for the root user when you're running it
locally i encourage you to change that
as quickly as you can because you don't
really want to have
a
password free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the mysql
environment
so do real write db dot connect
uh parenthesis error and we want to
throw an error message if the connection
isn't good
so if we do error
we will throw the
error message
to the log window
and
if we don't
then we'll write my superconnected
all right
and now
we want to connect that to our express
app
the next step we want to do after we
made our connection
is to go ahead and create a database so
we'll do both steps at the same one so
we're writing the script right now and
then we'll run the commands
in the terminal window so we can
actually create the database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create
a database
and let's write let's sql equals
create
database
i'm going to call the database node
mysql you could call it whatever you
want um but this is just a i know my sql
script
the db
query
sql
error
through error message
rest.send
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created let's go save
that
to demonstrate that we've connected and
we've created this let's go ahead
and we'll do node index.js
to run that and connect it to my sql
that's great
good first step and then we'll go to
window
i will go to localhost
3000 which is
the
default
connection but what you'll see is that
we've actually created the name of the
database has been changed to node by sql
so we've got an error message which we
expected and so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go ahead
and
we're going to say we want to listen
and if the error message if comes up to
3000
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of service started on
porch 3000.
so let's try that again
go to index.js
yep and server has started for 3000.
let me refresh that
i'm still getting an error message
and what we want to see is
let's go ahead and see how database
hasn't been created
so let's go and connect to
database
database
let's go ahead and click
create db
on port 3000. all right so by doing that
we write that command and that function
and that goes and creates our database
and we'll actually see
what we have now node mysql has been
created
great first start
now we have to go in and create some
tables we have no tables in there
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually create
and control everything that we want to
see in our windows so all of the work
that we're doing for creating a table
for creating the database um for
initializing the core files it's all
been done through js and so here we are
we're going to create a new table and
call it creating it's going to be called
the employee table
and so once we run the command create
employee it's going to create a table
has the employee fields which is going
to have an
id which would be an integer that will
go into auto increment they'll have a
name field
and we'll also put in a designation
field
and
[Music]
we'll have a primary key as well
keep it very simple right now
and let's just
put our db connection so that everything
connects effectively
okay so
everything goes correctly then we'll
have the message employee table created
so let's test this out
and
note
index.js
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to
so we've got node my sql so we're
connecting to the correct database
obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again yeah okay
database so database has the name
and because but note my sql there's no
fields in there yet
so let's go ahead and
put in create employee fields and let's
run the function that creates a new
table
and then
voila
we have a new table
and so
the next action we want to do is
actually
populate the table with a record
so
this starts becoming familiar so we're
not going to
put in a a single record we'll call it
employee one for right now
and
we'll write the
the function
in an empty one and when we run that
function
uh it'll actually go ahead and
create the it'll actually insert the
record into my sql
and then the name will be jake smith
and the designation
will be
a chief executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this make
yourself your own ceo because why not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
i'm going to insert into the employee
table
i'm just using some basic sql scripting
here
and what you'll see actually with
visual studio code is that it's actually
providing a lot of prompts to make it
easier to write your code
microsoft is looking to actually add
some ai
to visual studio code to actually start
auto completing
script which will be even easier
to write your code
all right so let's go run node
we've seen that i've been connected and
we'll grab the
function employee one
and let's go over to our express site
let's just go and we'll insert the
command employee one
employee has been added and we will just
validate this by going back to my sql
and we'll refresh it and you'll see
we click on the employee tables we
should now have an employee in there yep
there we go jake smith
hold on jake
first record
all right so we want to be able to now
select the employee
so let's go ahead and
do
that and we want to be able to easily
get the employee list
so let's use our sql command
and we'll do select
star which is everything
from the employee table so we're
actually playing everything from the
employee table
we're going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query is successful
we'll put everything in the console lock
results
all right let's give this a whirl
okay so
let's go and run our command
or localhost 3000
but get employee
and it says employee details fetch now
we go to the console window in visual
studio yep there we go we have now all
the packet information including the id
about jake smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our standard sql commands
and so we want to
be able to update the employee from a
browser
and as you can tell we're not using uh
any forms or any other types of records
we're just simply interacting um with
between the
uh browser the server and
the database
and the new name will be updated name
and just make sure we're updating your
appropriate record
i will show that we're matching against
id1
all right so that's wrong
[Music]
and
[Music]
jake smith is there
now go
and select
[Music]
slash one
we've now gone ahead and updated
the
jake
and jake smith's information
so let's click on
table
and we now see he says updated name i
know not very creative but
it allows you to see a change
and finally we can go ahead and delete
the record as well
so it's going to be similar to
update but i'm deleting instead
and going to delete
the record from the employee table
equals id or sorry
[Music]
and
[Music]
and then we want to be able to
show that the record has been deleted
okay
select the detailing
employee deleted and we go to our
database
gc
from the employee table that there are
no entries
the one-on-one record that was there has
been deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from
using your connection into mysql
right from node package manager
you can create a table
you can select your records
you can then
update any record that you selected
and finally you can delete any record
that
you want to be able to delete
you and we're going to be going through
some of the simple questions that you
would be asked during a node.js
interview uh what we're going to do is
we're actually going to break out the
section into three key areas that'll be
beginner questions there will be
intermediate questions and advanced
questions
and the expectation is as you go through
this video is that these questions could
be
pushed together as you're going through
the interview kind of think of it like
this is if you've answered the beginner
questions that you would get asked at
the beginning of the interview with
confidence and surety
then the client is going to then jump to
those intermediate advanced questions
quite quickly and they're looking for
people who can help them serve and solve
their problems at that more intermediate
and advanced level so let's just get
started
so the first question you're probably
going to be asked is you know you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for and essentially node.js is
one of the most popular if not the most
popular open source cross-platform
javascript programs and it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the the core
programming runtime and allows you to
build solutions extremely quickly in an
open source mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client size web applications
we'll see this later on and you may want
to talk a little bit about
using express js and how you can build
out apis uh to work with node.js and
connecting to databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store
data intensive applications that are
asynchronous and event driven in their
model
and this is important when you're
talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you're going to then ask be asking
how does nodejs work well node.js itself
is actually built on the v8 engine and
the v8 javascript engine is the same
engine that runs javascript in your
chrome web browser extremely fast
it allows for
high output and non-blocking out through
your i o input outputs and is a single
threaded event loop
so you're going to be then asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications
probably referencing the web
applications is a really good starting
point because here you can actually talk
about maybe some examples that you've
done where you're building out some of
these web applications
indeed one of the things that you want
to be consistently doing and peppering
your answers with is examples of work
that you have done
now it doesn't matter if those examples
are purely experimental or
training examples that you've done the
fact that you've actually worked with
node.js and created a distributed system
or a web application is really valuable
because it shows that the person that
you're meeting with that you have
knowledge and understanding and
practical experience of applying the
theory of working with new js with the
practice of working with nodejs
so be asked about you know your
essentially the i o refers to the
transfer of data in and out of
a system and that's really it you know
there's a reason why google calls their
conference io it's the transfer of data
in and out of our brains at that
conference the application is same here
it's about moving data in and out of
systems through using node.js
and that every um event can be
tracked um whether it's on a physical
device and network or files within a
system again it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
going to be asked yo can you explain the
difference between front front-end and
back-end development and this is a
question that i get asked a lot when i'm
meeting with clients um you know people
get really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development
bottom line front-end is what gets
resolved inside of your web browser or
the app on your
mobile device back end is what gets
resolved um essentially um what we call
the the back office or server side
applications but it's becoming more and
more synonymous for what gets run in the
cloud
so web applications um really get a lot
of the functionality of a web
application gets run in the front end
anything with css html5 uh client-side
javascript so we can get right in the
front-end everything else such as
connecting to a database um gets run
behind the scenes in the back end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like graphics is going to be on the
front end uh apis are going to be run on
the back end and then just finally some
of the scripting languages are used on
on the front end so html css javascript
those are all common
core scripting languages that you would
use
you can use frameworks such as angularjs
and react.js or vue
those would be a front-end frameworks
backend frameworks will include java php
python and node.js are some of the
back-end technologies you'd also
throw in there
net as well i mean it's just the whole
you know litany of front-end and
back-end technologies and frameworks
that you can use um and this is a
actually a good point to kind of explain
the experience you have outside of just
working with node.js but other
technologies that you've been working
with that potentially that the client is
also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you're going to respond
is do you mean node package manager and
the reason why you want to respond like
that is that you want to qualify their
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them uh includes
references to mpm
so you're going to be asking you know so
okay you tell me um what it is you know
can you go into a little bit more um
details you know so you can provide two
main functionalities and so one of them
is being able to
manage online repositories of modules
and packages um so you can go to like
search.nodejs.org and you can find a
packages that you can install into your
solution
such as express.js and it also provides
a command line utility that allows you
to manage
your packages very quickly through
terminal window or command line
i use vs code a lot visual studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows me to interact
with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules um in
node.js they're essentially like
javascript libraries so you can think of
some of the javascript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for node.js and to run on the server and
there are ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance
if we're creating a web server you can
actually use the require commands to be
able to require that the server be there
so the example we have on the right hand
side
shows that we really do need to have
http which is a web server and we
require that to be installed
and so that if you're running that
npm package it will actually install the
http server and then you can actually
write some code to actually then listen
on the local host port 2000 for where
you'll be running your application
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that uh come
with node.js right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we also referenced that just
earlier on http is a core module for
running a
web server
you have a utility function that is
useful for developers to
assess and features within your node.js
project you have a url
module for any url passing you'd be
doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's being worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep your storage
of files um to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over back-end technologies
such as java and php and particularly
gyro it's a very mature stable language
it's been around for more than 20 years
you know php
runs some of them the
most powerful and largest websites out
there such as facebook so why would you
use node.js well the first response is
kind of a gimme but it is really fast
and if you watched any of the videos
that we've done on node.js
building out solutions and developing
the solutions you'll see just how fast
it is
the second is the
really kind of the secret source with
node.js is the node packet manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as express
or [ __ ] as a database into your
solution
really quickly and there's over 50 000
bundles available for node package
manager
if you're building out a
real-time application that's data
intensive and you need to have apis
quickly developed then node.js is
another great it's really the great
solution for you it allows you to build
out these solutions really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client due to
the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up
node.js because you have that common
language of javascript
and on top of that javascript is the
world's most popular
scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular and node.js
and so the reason why this question may
come up is the person interviewing you
is seeing whether or not you do know the
difference between a front-end
framework and a back-end framework and
this is one of those questions where you
can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other
so angular is a front-end development
framework whereas node.js is a
server-side in framework other
differences though between the actual
frameworks themselves is that angular is
written in typescript which is a
modification of javascript node.js is
written in c and c plus plus
angular is used for building out single
page
client-side web applications and so
that's a key word there is client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side network
applications
so
again the two complement each other
angular splits web applications into the
mvc and model view control components
whereas node.js generates a lot of
database grades it does more than that
as well but you can think of node.js
that glue to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so um you're going to
probably be asking what is um
the most popular database used with
node.js and there are a couple um
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database
mysql is also very popular and that's a
more traditional relational database
you would go with mongodb for really
more modern solutions when you're
looking at creating an application
that's going to really scale into just
managing masses and masses
of data that has to be
created read updated and deleted very
very quickly
for
some of the other popular libraries that
you use for node.js express.js is a very
popular one i really like working with
express.js allows me to build out web
applications really quickly uh more
importantly it allows me to build out
apis very quickly and which you know
apis are essentially web applications
themselves but being able to do that
very quickly with a framework like
express.js is very useful
mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a [ __ ] database really
easy so um here is an example of
express.js which is a in itself really a
flexible budge a solution that you can
do lots with and mongoose which is a
more
focused solution
which allows
you know to you make it easier to
connect to your databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explain this earlier on that you
can actually build out uh applications
that run on the cloud why would you you
know what's are the pros and cons so a
pro is that uh node.js is extremely fast
a processing an event based model uh it
really is fast a con is if you have
something that is a very heavy
computational task it's not so good at
that now i will caveat that this is that
node.js is getting better all the time
and so
you might have to be provide an example
of what a very heavy computational task
is and that may be
calculating
a risk on an insurance application
against
many many variables that may be
something that's seen as computationally
very heavy but what you can do in that
example is you can offload the task to
another solution that's designed for it
and use apis to pass the data back and
forth
pro
javascript is used for building out your
applications with
node.js great lots of people know
javascript
a
restriction and again this is evolving
as javascript itself evolves is that
when you do a callback you may end up
doing lots of nested call backs
if you're doing something that's very
complicated again another way around the
con and so this is one of the things
that i always look for is if you have a
blocker or a barrier
how do you get around that barrier and
so for instance when you're talking uh
to your recruiter
you can say look the reason why i use
node.js is that it's fast it's events
driven i can use javascript uh there are
some challenges and but what i do to get
around those challenges are and that's
where you can say that you know you may
run the complex script off and you may
write that in net or java or php and
then use an api to do the response back
into node.js so you get the benefits of
both worlds but minimize the investment
in having to manage a complex
environment such as java versus a
relatively simple environment with
node.js
the node package manager makes it
extremely easy to access just an awful
lot of functionality with over 50 000
packages there's a package for that
so from being able to have a
tool that creates unique identifiers
that you might need to have for
generating content that gets posted into
a database through to being able to
connect to databases through you know to
running so many different solutions and
the npm package manager with its access
to so many different packages makes it
great
for
getting access to all that content now
khan is working with relational
databases with node.js isn't as easy as
a nosql database now you can do it and
there are ways around that and what i
would do when this question comes up is
always kind of pivot to say hey this is
how you can actually then get around
building out that application
pro for node.js designed for streaming
huge amounts of data in and out a con is
that node.js is singles threaded so it
can be cpu intensive
but again there are ways around that and
a good way around that is scaling your
solution in an elastic environment such
as the cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external library and so to import an
external library the command is the
required command and so an example we
have here is uh you can start a variable
and the variable's going to be for http
and you're going to then require the
http
service and that means that the
application itself won't run unless the
external library the http library is
installed
okay so those were our introductory
questions for node.js this kind of pivot
and take a look at the intermediate
questions that you would be asked
so what does event-driven programming
mean so event-driven programming means
that if something happens something else
will happen in response so for instance
if you click a mouse
that mouse click is an event that means
something has to respond to that event
uh just think of it as cause and effect
it's just the basic motion of physics so
that's what event driven programming
means
you also look at it as a callback
function
so that when an element is executed
something will happen in response
so what is an event loop in node.js
so an event loop in node.js is when you
do an asynchronous call and
what that essentially means is that
you are sending out
data and then a non-blocking input
output
from node.js is pulling data back in
what is an event emitter in nodejs so an
event emitter has really two areas of
focus one is that it manages the classes
that hold all the objects
within your event and we have an example
of this on the right hand side
and then whenever an event actually is
thrown
the functions are then called on that
event synchronously
so for instance we have in our example
on the right hand side we create an
event and then we have the functions and
that executed in a series from
that event
so let's talk about the api functions in
node.js so there's two types
one is an asynchronous non-blocking
function
and the second is a synchronous blocking
function and the difference between the
two of them is asynchronous is that
there is no structure to the order
for how the
api is resolved synchronous means that
when the feedback from the api is
received you have to execute
the response in a series for how the
response is sent to you
so what is a package.json file so the
package json file is at the heart of our
node.js
package when we actually will initialize
a solution a folder to be a node.js
package
you'll find that the package itself
holds all of the metadata that's
particular to the project you're working
on such as project name version
requirements it is you have to have
installed in the root of the directory
for the project and again look at any of
the videos that we have on node.js we do
have demonstrations within those videos
that actually then go through and break
out
how to create that root package and
you'll see how you can actually then go
ahead and update the instructions or the
metadata within the package
so here we have an example of what that
metadata looks like so again this kind
of continues that question of what is a
package.json file and you may be asked
you know what is the metadata and why is
it important and the metadata is a
basic uh json collection of pairing of
a key details such as name version
description and then the custom version
that you put so for instance under name
you could create a name for your project
there can't be any spaces uh what is the
version and the description and what is
the main or starting path
for the solution typically that would be
index.js but it could be anything.js but
index.js is typical simply because
index.html is the starting point for a
typical web application
so how would you use a url module in
node.js
so with the url module what it allows
you to do is really two things one is
that it provides the resolution of a url
for utilities in your application
and then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example um we have the url
and
the response it would give
for that url which would then be a year
and month um and it'd be in a readable
format so they would read out as
2020 and then the month
so
what is express.js and you've heard me
mention this a couple of times in the
video and we actually have a separate
video on express.js
but express.js is a web application
framework that allows you to build out
web solutions
for both mobile and traditional desktop
right inside of node.js so it's very
easy to use being able to install web.js
is as simple as requiring express to be
installed in the example that we have
here on the screen it's a full solution
of showing how to actually build out a
solution with web.js
so in this example you start off the
first two lines require express to be
installed and the store comes from node
packet manager then we have a simple
application that will then send to the
browser window
a hello world message confirming that
express is up and running and then the
third block of content starting with
virus server actually will define the
port
where your application is going to run
so in this instance
the port is going to run on localhost
and the
port will be port 8081
and so you can actually go to localhost
colon8081 and when you do that that will
trigger the application that will
forward up the message hello world and
it's all coming from express.js
so what are streams in node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth within your application and
there's really four different types of
streams there's readable writeable
duplex and transform
the readable one stream through which
data can be read
the writable streams that you can
actually write to
a duplex is a stream where is both
readable and writeable
and
transform our streams that can be
manipulate the data
while it is being read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so say for instance we want
to install uh something like express so
if you wanted to install express what
you would do is you would just write
them inside of your project um you want
to go to terminal window and write in
the command npm install express
if you want to update the dependencies
within your node package manager to
update all of them all you have to do is
write the command npm update all
dependencies
and then if you want to explicitly
uninstall a dependency such as
express.js
that's using the uninstall command and
so that would again be going to terminal
window and you would type npm uninstall
express
and again it's really easy to create a
simple server in node.js that will run a
simple command
the http service is actually built into
node.js you don't need to use express.js
i i typically use express.js when i want
to do a web server because typically
what i find is that i will want to go
and do something more complicated but if
you want to do something that
illustrates just the core functionality
within node.js you can actually just
require the core http service that
actually comes as part of node.js and
then you can actually then go ahead and
tell it to create a service and then to
write in plain text a command um or text
string such as in this case it'll be
hello world and that would pop out and
then the final line is to then listen
that if you go to a web browser that's
on port
127.0.01 or localhost
and go to
port colon 8080 once you actually go to
that that will trigger this application
and you'll get the text hello world pop
up on your screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so all the apis
in node.js are asynchronous which means
that they are non-blocking which means
you can run them continuously
and scale around that which is just
fantastic one of the reasons why node.js
can scale so fast and the eighth means
that the apis can return data send data
after it's been called and really
increase the efficiency of events as
they are triggered within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js and so the example that we have
on the left hand side allows us to
trigger async and it's using the async
function and as you can see in this
example
it's actually something that can be done
very quickly in this example we're
actually
making a command to logo host and app
that's running on port 3000 and then
depending on
what we get if there's an error message
and then we'll have error message go to
the console log which is the terminal
window and if we get a response to an
application
then we'll actually get a positive
response which would be fetched response
so
again very quickly and easy that you use
the async function uh to be able to
build out and you to get your
asynchronous code
so what is the purpose of module exports
so a module export is a way to
encapsulate your the entire code for a
solution in a single package in a single
file and then you can then
share that with other developers so
you're all working from the same
environment
so what is a callback function in
node.js a callback function is
essentially that once you run and you've
triggered an event and the response has
been given
you want to be able to then have a
callback to validate that the task is
complete
all right let's move on to the final set
of questions which is advanced node.js
questions
so what is reppl in node.js so repl
stands for read eval print and loop and
this is a reference to the
unix and linux background that node.js
has
so rapple will form the following tasks
the reader will be actually
passing the javascript you'll read that
and store it in memory eval
takes and evaluates the data structure
print will then print the results often
on the console window or onto a web page
and then loop and loops the above
command until the user presses ctrl c
twice
what is the control flow function
so the control flow function is a piece
of code that runs between several of the
asynchronous functions and that's it it
actually controls how those functions
execute
so how control flow controls the
function calls and it does it through
four ways one is it controls the order
of execution
it collects the data it limits the
concurrency and then it also calls the
next step in a program again this is the
management tool for how your functions
are called within node.js
so what is the difference between fork
and spawn methods in node.js
so the essential difference between the
two of them is that if you use the fork
method it will actually trigger and
create a new instance of the v8 engine
the engine running node.js
and will then run the application in
that new instance
with spawn
it's somewhat similar it doesn't
actually generate a new v8 instance so
it's actually creating a new process but
it's within the same v8 instance as the
previous application that it was spawned
from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in node.js
so with the buffer class what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data of a set of
arrays and integers and the memory
allocation outside of the v8 heap buffer
class is used because pure javascript is
not compatible with binary data
what is piping in node.js
so
piping is the ability to connect the
output of one stream to another stream
that could be a data stream it could be
any stream that you're working with
but it does normally get used to pass
data from one stream to another
so what are some of the flags used in
the rewrite operation files
so r dash is used for read w's for
opening a file for writing
a dash is opening a file for appending
so the collection that you have here you
don't have to really memorize all of
them but to have a few of them in the
back of your mind is always a good
reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so
the syntax you would use would be
the fs dot open and that would then open
up a file
explain to me what callback hell is
so callback hell also known as the
pyramid of doom is when you have too
many
nested unreadable and unmanageable
callbacks intensively cycle within each
other and they're constantly reading to
each other and they're not able to
resolve the solution
and uh this is a you know it's a big
problem and this is what why it's called
callback hell because you're not able to
finalize the the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so a reactor pattern is a concept of
non-blocking i o operations
can you explain to me the test pyramid
for node.js so the test pyramid and this
is standard for testing uh for all
devops is really split into three key
areas you have unit tests integration
tests and then end to end or e2e tests
the unit tests are tests that you
actually do in your raw code
that you're working on and the goal
there is to be able to validate that the
code you're writing is consistently
working
integration allows you to
have tests that integrate your raw code
that you're working within your
application with other areas of an
application and then end to end is the
whole system the whole interface as it
were
for your solution
describe the exit codes of node.js
so annexa code is a specific code that
identifies the end of a specific process
and examples of exit codes are unused
uncalled fatal exception
fatal error
internal javascript evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is
a middleware can you explain the concept
of middleware in nodejs
so
with middleware it is the ability to be
able to connect to a system and get data
from it
that's outside of node.js so
this may be executing a type of code or
updating a modifying request in response
to a specific type of object and
finishing the request response cycle
can you explain to me what are the types
of http requests that you may use when
working with node.js
there are actually quite a lot but four
of them that you might use would be get
post
head and delete
and these are if you've done any uh web
application before particularly worked
with forms inside of a web application
you're probably very familiar certainly
with get and post
get is the request to retrieve data post
is generally used for changing stating
and data uh head is similar to get um
but also ask for a response if there's
no body content so if you're using if
you're developing an api this would be a
good one to use and delete is used to
delete the predetermined source
so how would you connect to mongodb
database and with node.js and you use
that using the [ __ ] client and the
example we have on the left hand side
and illustrates that
what is the use of node underscore emv
and so the node unscrew emv is an
environment variable that stands for
node environment in express server so
the example we have on the right hand
side allows you to illustrate how you
would do that for say a production
environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so
the timing functions that you could use
here set timeout and then clear timeout
and you to schedule code execution that
you'd have inside of your application
you also have set interval clear
interval to execute a block of code up
multiple times in your application
set intermediate and clear intermediate
to
execute code and that is at the end of
your application and with that we come
to the end of this full course tutorial
if you enjoyed watching the video do
give it a thumbs up comment your doubts
below and our experts will answer them
for you thank you so much for being here
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep coding and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you